So, Malfus, you are right now running in a green field, sun shining on you.
You hear the footsteps of your sister behind you as you walk up to your father, as he
stands above a lookout tower, sort of human man-made structure. And you fly up to the
structure and give him his lunch essentially. He looks back at you as he puts his hand on
your head and rubs it. He goes, "So, how's your training going, son?"
"Oh, it's good. I started to get the hang of these wings. The weather is quite nice
a lot for a few days." It has been, it has been. He looks at the skies and he says to you,
"I just have a bad feeling about what's happening." Well, a few of the outposts last night
were taken out. You still don't know what happened. Well, you have some time to kill. So, how
about this? You spar with your old man and then you go back, I finish my lunch and I'll
follow you home. How does that sound?
"This time I will be true." "I'll sure little man sure." As he flies down, he lands
on the grass. He touches it, sits down and looks at your sister as he calls her in and
hugs her as your sister looks at you and she goes double thumbs as she says, "Hey, get
him, get him this time." Your father stands up and he looks at you. He says, "So, where
are we last time?" Yes. As you might know, our people have come from a line of beings that
have certain strengths. One of those strengths we have to harness from time to time. I know
you're still not very used to resisting just blunt heads, but maybe we should get a
custom to that, shall we? As he takes his fist and he signals you to put out an arm in front
of him. He swings his arm, not with full strength, but a fair amount of strength put in. The
first hit lands and it sends you kind of flying to the back. As you fall down, he crouches
down to you and says, "Maybe I went too hard." How about this? You try to hit me and
you look at my posture. How I'm trying to resist the hit. Okay, stand up. He pulls out
his arm in the same way that he positioned yours and then he asks you to hit him. You punch
him on the side of the arm, but as soon as you touch the arm, you feel an impact, but you
do feel that you're hitting like a still object instead of a person. Your arm kind of stings
as he goes. Remember that feeling, son? You might need this sometime. Flash forward in
your dream. The surrounding is now lit with fire as a bunch of cannons are firing all around
you. In your arms, you have your little sister as you're trying to run away. Right in front
of you, you run into a marine as he pulls out a spear and tries to attack you. The position,
the angle, it feels right to you as it hits you, pitching the spear breaks in half and you
wake up. Gasping for air beside you, Roma, lying, snoring as usual. And you realize that
this is not where you want to be at this point. You want to get to her. You want to save her.
As soon as you wake up, you hear an impact at the side of the ship as it explodes and a
fair bit of smoke starts to fill in in the lower deck. Okay. At this point, I want to make
sure who do you think will wake up from the impact? Bob, Baptiste, Nalphist, Roma.
Well, I'm already awake. Yeah, you're already awake. I'm running about to see what's going
on. Bob, are you going to wake up? Baptiste, Roma. I'm not sure. Can I roll to see? What can
you roll to see? Just do a 1 to 20. Yeah, just roll a D20. Whoever wants to wake up, just
do it. Yes, I wake up instantly. Okay. Is that how did you sleep? Roma, do you wake up and
try to follow up or are you fast asleep? Not please.
You're so those impact that we heard. Yes. Okay. You wake up, Roma. Okay. Just because he's
not responding, I'm just going to say he is sleeping. Yeah. Can you hear me now? No, I can
say Bob, Malfus and Baptiste are going to run up and what they are seeing at the Stark
Night lights, you see some cannons pointed towards you. You see a part of the ship here, right
around here, is just blown off. Strangely, you don't see any more smoke coming out of it,
except for the few smoke particles you saw below Malfus. Are we supposed to see something?
No, I'm just explaining what's happening here. What do you see?
As you said, I don't hear this stuff happening. I'm like, look at it. Yeah. And you see Daniel,
Chloe and Ben are already scrounging up some of the cannons from some of the positions
of the ship to fire back. You guys get up and you hear someone speak through Denen Mushi,
kind of like a transmitter above deck here, like a large Denen Mushi transmitter above.
You see a voice? You're not really familiar with it. Sorry, it's not. You hear a voice.
You're not really familiar with it. Say, it's under now or die. You will keep attacking
you and we will not stop. The spiders, you've done well to report your findings. Now,
capture these pirates and you will be set free. Otherwise, you die with them. Daniel turns back,
looks at you. Baptiste goes, I'm fucking knew you were trouble. He puts his hand down on the deck as
cold bars essentially encapsulate around you, all three of you. And right now, you are in
restrained by these bars. Roma, feel free to step in whenever you want.
I'm so free. Yeah, yeah. Just whenever you wake up, let me see.
He's waking up and less. Yeah.
Make sure that gets me. I have the stats open here.
Damn, Bob rolled a net 20 off rip. Okay. Well, that's just it for your data.
Yeah, he wasted his one that row. Yeah. Sorry, Bob. Should have gave a sleep.
Right. And now I handed over to you guys. What do you want to do?
Part. You're going to call us.
You just betrayed us and you call us trouble.
Yeah, well, what do you think called these guys? I did.
I just said that. What? I called you a traitor for calling you.
You've been a thorn in my way, all the way through. The best we can do is get rid of you at this point
and wash our hands clean. The Marines will let us go and you won't be in our way anyway.
They were really thinking they'd just gonna let you leave.
You're in the open island.
Well, we've already talked it through in detail. So don't worry about that.
They're not going to believe you and they will definitely believe us.
As that is happening, if you want to do anything else, you can do that. Otherwise, I couldn't
swash to what's going to happen on the ship and the marine ship. Can I just interject?
Like, Roma still asleep. Baptiste, you can remind them that you gave that lady the journal and everything.
So that way, like, you can remind Daniel and be like, hey, we gave that lady everything.
She's going to report it. You're going to go down with us.
I don't think he cares.
Yeah, I don't think he cares at this point.
All right.
As far as he's safe.
Yeah. As the skies are becoming clear, the moonlight shines through and you can see more clearly
as to who's on the ship at this point. You see the same armors you saw back on
spirit cliffs, the marines in the same armors pointing cannons toward the ship, as a familiar face
steps out at this point. And as usual, followed by two of the marines,
as he goes, all right. Nice to meet you again, Lunarion.
This time you won't escape. You have plans for you and your comrades.
To be honest, I could not care less about the rest, but you too will be valuable in the
ongoing research that we have part taken in with the Mugen Industries.
Right. So will you surrender or will you fight? That's the question.
This.
That's he will start shaking like not from your but anger.
How far is their ship?
The ship is, let me see.
It would be about 50 feet. 56 feet.
Again, you're restrained by the bars currently.
That's not a breakout. You can try to break the coal bars. You can try on a non-strike and try to
break them.
Yes.
Yeah, that's enough to break it.
Roll the damage just to see if it's lesser than the actual strength of the bar.
Yeah, it should be able to break the bar through. As you just sponge through the bar,
it crumbles. It has enough space so you can move out, but Malthus, you cannot pop get moved out too.
You're too big.
Break it.
I want to charge a Daniel.
I don't know. Go ahead.
It's going to be a surprise round, so you can do a advantage.
I don't know.
See, actually, you want to fight for a delicious one and grapple.
What's up to you?
I'll be.
Yep, it's going to hit.
I'll roll the damage.
You get a bonus action on a surprise round too, right?
Yeah.
There you go.
17 and 19.
Oh, sorry, 15.
32.
As you knock out essentially like the armor around his arm, it just shatters as you punch
at the same location again as this time it just gushes out blood and he kind of stumbles back.
Move you here.
At the same time, where we'll go.
So you chose the other way around.
I couldn't have hoped for any less.
In the name of Commodore Bricks of G45, you are ordered to surrender.
Lunarion Baptiste.
Resistance will be punished under Article 66.
Celestial theft.
Engrage Project Wonderland now.
As you orders that,
Malthus, you see something flying up above in the air and
winged armor drops right around here in front of Warro.
You can see somewhat what it looks like.
Let me.
My warehouse?
Oh, you're not in here.
God damn it.
No, that's what I meant.
Sorry.
Okay.
So this is what you see right in front of you.
A silver armor, clad.
You see it's a tall woman with white wings.
As it lands in front,
Warro commands the thing to attack with Wonderland.
Your orders are as follows.
Capture the two Lunarions alive.
The rest can be discarded.
If the spiders put again, put any
contention or they try to betray us, kill them as well.
Again, I repeat, the Lunarions are needed alive.
Got it.
The being in front just nods as you guys can now get in combat.
All the needles have started.
Yeah, yeah.
So at this point, you will start to hear the commotion.
Yes, Rangely, Veil and Serka are missing.
They have not shown up.
Hey, I'm just going to say this.
Just like Bapji said, I'm just waiting for somebody to wake my ass up.
All right, Bob, that's going to be you.
All right, I'm going to say this.
Bob, you have one move to do.
And Malphas, you have one move to do before anything happens.
Okay, so am I inside the bars?
No, you're free to move because the bar that was broken by Bapthes
should be able to, you'll be able to slide through that.
Okay, so since I don't see the others, I'm assuming they're like lead.
So I'm going to like whisper to my owl Marlene, find Roma,
find Roma, Veil and Serka and bring them here.
And then my owl will fly to the inside of the square.
So can you repeat?
What did you say?
Can you, like, hello?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
I just lost the fucking, whatever you were saying.
Okay, go ahead again.
So since the others, I'm assuming are asleep.
So I'm just, I, he allowed it to my owl,
and sorry, whisper to my owl, find Roma, Veil and Serka.
And then my owl will fly to the inside of the ship.
All right, your owl will just go down through the stairs.
And it's going to pack at Roma.
Roma, you wake up.
You see an owl sitting on you.
I'll let out a nasty disgusting fart first.
It's a mechanical owl.
It can smell.
Yeah, it's going to like, I grab onto you with the
talents and like try to pull you.
It will try to pull you, not that you can't.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to be like, what the fuck is this thing?
You see all the commotion and the loud noises going out above.
Yeah, with me, and it's like, it's pulling you to the deck,
or to the upper deck.
Are you following it?
Yeah.
Okay, you follow it above the deck.
And now you start to see what is happening.
Yeah, and your owl at this point will go up to the mast.
It will loop around the ship.
And it will just come back down to you.
It has failed to find whale and cerca.
Malthus, what are you doing?
Well, bring this goddamn cage so I can also get out.
Bring the cage.
Can I just move over here because I have already,
I've already cleared him giving the orders discard the others.
So I don't want to be discarded.
But why does the cage is already partially broken?
Yes, yes.
This is a lot of enemies.
In the last.
It's a long bit.
Wait a minute, fuck me as a thing.
Wait, what?
Why are you clicking martial arts?
Yeah, I clicked the wrong thing.
What was it?
Like how he goes.
There you go.
You probably despite a lot.
You don't put us in the right.
Put it in.
That bitch.
It's going to make more sense at the end of today's session.
Why this is happening to you, but I will make more sense.
20.
You could do another one.
Well, I'm stuck in the cage, guys.
Bonus.
Hold the damage.
Yeah, that's going to be enough to break the integrity.
So you can just spread them apart and break like a couple.
As you spread your wings and you spread, sorry, move out of the cage,
the cage at this point shatters completely because he also lost consciousness
while Baptiste was hitting.
I'm just assuming all of this happens at the same kind of time.
Baptiste lands up on Chondanio.
He lost concentration on the cage itself.
All right, now I'm going to start combat with Chloe.
And.
Survive.
Yeah, good enough.
All right, it's going to be Chloe's turn.
Chloe is going to attack you, Baptiste.
Twice.
16 hits.
And 17 hits too.
Okay, let me do the damage.
Yeah.
It's going to be five total.
She got as he should have died back on the island.
We should have left them to burn.
Uh, you should have one.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. That the fuck, who is in the...
Stern is it? No, no, it's B-ben. Ben is going to...
grow, and he's going to run up to you.
Map-tease and itch you with the Zinefist.
Once, take Daniel and Dash away.
26 hits.
I'm going to do damage. Let me do that.
You see like an immense pressure, build on top of you as his fist just lands on you.
Again, you face through part of it, but the shock itself does a lot of damage.
Malfa's suture. No opportunity to sit in the drain away. Yeah.
At 20. Were you waiting? Ben?
Go ahead.
Yeah, just do the crit damage instead.
Oh, I guess you can work with that. Five plus three.
Yes, I know.
You hit as Ben is retrieving Daniel. You hit him as...
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
That was cough and I'm sorry.
No, no, no, no. Malfa's was doing another strike.
Oh my god, barely. Almost another crit.
Touch him and barely hits.
No, no, no, that hits.
It's going to be another four.
It's going to bring him down to...
There you go. He's still trying to retrieve Daniel
and make some distance between you and...
Baptiste. Chloe at this point is probably here.
The first marine...
What?
On who?
Either Daniel or Ben.
They were both right next to me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For God. You can try to make an opportune attack on both of them as they're leaving.
Oh, I as well. You as well, yeah.
I'll try to do it again.
This was far Daniel or Ben. Daniel, okay.
Mine was Ben again.
Yeah, that doesn't hit.
On my screen, it wasn't sitting on the 20 and then rolled.
Yeah.
Oh, you know.
Too strong.
You can try another one on Ben.
That's only a one reaction.
Yeah, you do have only one reaction.
Okay.
As Ben successfully retrieves, as you both try to
kid them before they're leaving your swings miss.
And it's going to be the marine behind
Voss runs up here and it's going to command these marines to point their cannons.
And that's going to be its turn.
Baptiste your turn.
Let's get
lost by
what's the
10 feet.
Yeah.
I would like to move here.
Okay, Chloe is going to get a opportunity to attack.
She's going to miss.
All right, go ahead.
Okay, my arms.
Okay.
Um.
Uh, third of all.
This is a 10 feet of me.
You mean we're technically Ben.
Isn't that 10 feet?
Yeah, yeah, sure.
So all three of them have to make a deck saving throw.
Daniel fails.
Only that.
Neil fails.
That's good enough for me because I want to take one of their mountain.
It's going to be Daniel.
Uh,
okay.
So as all your arms form, an impact is felt through as your arms
stretch out and try to hit all three of them at once.
But only Daniel gets like a grace of that arm
to his body as he's thrown.
Uh, is it is it any other thing?
Is it does he get thrown or something?
No.
Um, it's just a damage.
Okay, then it's fine then.
Okay.
And that's a bump that chin and then I was still like to punch him.
I still like to punch him.
Punch his face off.
There's no five feet.
But I'm still going to move forward just so if he tries to move again, I can hit him.
And then I will
and it's not going to hit.
That's fine.
At this point, Baptiste is like in rage by what Daniel has done to him.
He rushes through, tries to land another head as Ben just
like covers him with his arm, metal arm.
Uh,
it's cheating him like a baby.
Yeah.
Uh,
what?
Ben is holding Daniel.
Technically, Daniel is graphic.
Yeah.
So that means I should have had a bench.
I mean, and now you're technically hitting Ben.
So as long as like he's in the vicinity, you can.
If Daniel is being held,
you're aware of what you think he's doing.
He's never.
He's protecting him.
He's just not going to sit there and you fucking pummel him down.
No.
Ruling is fine, but at this point you got to understand in character.
He's trying to protect him.
I won't give advantage on that.
Okay.
Um, the, uh,
winged thing at this point will fly up like around 10 feet and just dash directly towards
the first lorarian it sees, which is going to be Malfus.
As it lands right in front of you, it will.
He would.
Everything on to you.
So he dashed in the top.
No, not dashed like moved.
I should say move.
It's going to attack again.
That fails.
That's misses.
Only one hits.
And I'm going to do the damage for that.
There's no way.
There you go.
Uh, as these, once again, what was it?
There should be.
There should be seven damage off.
There was no.
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh, I see, I see one D6.
Yeah, and five radians.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's fine.
Um, it should do it automatically.
That's what I was like, yeah, either it should be 30 or 15.
Radiant.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So as, as this feature lands in front of you,
Baptiste, you, sorry, Malfus, you feel like kind of a sensation that
you know this, you know this person.
As the thing lands a part, lands a punch on like the right side of you,
the other two hits come at you as you try to like move your head around to dodge them.
But the same hit that landed on you on the right side,
it carries another shockwave that kind of lifts you a bit up off the ground.
Uh, as you lad back,
you don't see much inside the visor that is covering this person's head,
but the wings definitely do remind you of something.
Um, Roma, it's your turn.
And I'm going to kill you.
Yeah.
Roma, go fuck shit up.
Roma still asleep.
No, no, I'm still here.
Sorry, I was talking to my wife.
Bob, hello Bob.
Hello.
I'm your sideboard.
Each one of their helmets has a self-destruct in it.
We saw it on the island.
I don't know how to figure out how that does.
I'm going to fuck shit up.
Give me one second.
I'll be right back.
All right.
We can, uh, let's say hold, hold, uh,
Roma's turn whenever he's back. I'll go through the next people.
Um, the rest of the Marines are now going to use their turn to point their
cannons to one Baptist, to, to Malfus.
And the third Marine is going to dash here in hopes to try to board the ship
in his next turn.
Uh, it's Daniel Stern as he
shoves Ben off as he lands in front of you Baptist.
He goes, I was waiting for this.
Oh, you don't know how much I, I hold myself.
I try to leave in your sleep, but I have to wait.
But now you die.
And he's going to launch a hard strike against you Baptist,
as he's going to crawl it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
If you're
that's 11 more damage right at you Baptist.
If you want to do something, you can.
Uh, otherwise we just move on.
Do you have anything in response or no?
Probably not, right?
Hello.
Baptist you're muted.
All right, so he just pierces right through one of the, um, arms and part of your shoulder.
Uh, as he lands right behind, he's not going to leave your five feet.
And uh, this is going to be end of his turn.
The first class marine, this one is going to go here and it
deplies a rope that binds to the mast.
So these guys can come over.
That's going to be his turn.
Uh, Voss is going to skywalk up to the mast here.
As he looks down at you Baptist and goes,
what did I tell you?
I told you I'd find you and I would capture you.
And now that we know that there's more, it's all the better.
Another thing that I forgot to mention is he points toward here at this angle of the ship.
As you see two bodies hanging off, uh, off the ship.
And you see their faces at this point.
One of the bodies is off red and the other body is off someone that you know of, uh, Bob.
It's your mom.
Oh, he went there.
Both of them dead hanged and uh, yeah.
One of them, yes.
Uh, this marine is going to jump here, dash here, and that's going to be the end of his turn.
Bob is your turn.
What do I see again?
You're the body of your mom hanged off this edge.
She's dead.
Wow, I planned a lot for my turn, but you have to go there.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So Bob is going to pretend to not see that.
And, uh, I mean, I'm trying to think what the character do.
So Bob is going to pretend to not see that, not to not even recognize that.
And ask Malfa's because there's like a lot of, there's the whole army and ask Malfa's,
what was the plan now?
Are you planning on beating everyone?
Are we surrendering?
The plan has to survive, Bob.
Well, there's, oh, sorry.
You don't have to mouth us or back this.
Yeah, I asked back this because he's the one going to have her.
Bob, you heard him.
They only want to meet Malfa's life.
The rest of you, then.
I see.
I need to survive, right?
I'm going to yell out at whoever the voro guy is, the guy with the weird mask and say,
and I'm going to yell out like, hey, you, didn't you say you wanted these guys alive?
This guy is almost dying and I pointed at Baptiste and say, he's, he's going to die if
nothing happens.
And then I ask him, and I, can I, I am a very good doctor?
Can I heal him?
Can I, can I can take care of him if you want?
Because you wanted him alive.
God, David, Bob, I told you there's a self-destruct in the helmet.
What do you want me to do right now?
You want me to go and start taking it's head off?
Yes, I heard Bob.
Okay, so that's what I did.
What's going to look at you as he goes?
Bob, that was Bob.
Basilisk. You know, you know that name?
Bob has a full bank face right now.
This, what?
That was the last thing she said.
While we hang there, you call out your name.
And this, this is what you say?
Are these really your words after seeing your mother, dead lying in front of you?
No matter, I don't need you, boy.
Spiders know their place.
They won't kill them unless they want to be killed.
Isn't that right, Daniel?
Daniel at this point will just put a finger up to wall, as he says,
fuck you. I'm going to kill all of them. I don't care.
Okay, Bob, you have anything to say or do we just move on?
Are you just blind at this point?
You won't go into a rage after not taking your mother doing in this turn.
If I could, I would, but Bob is going to do absolutely nothing on this turn.
Oh, fine. I think you should stay true to your character and not do anything that's out of character.
That's probably going to work better in long term.
Okay, this, it already had a turn. What the fuck am I, which suit am I moving?
Oh, this one.
Oh, yeah, Roma. It's your turn.
Oh, shit. You already know what's happening.
I'm going to shut up.
Okay, we're going to your rage. Let me actually turn it on because I always forget. There you go.
I'm going right here.
I'm going to rip the helmet off of those whatever the, because I'm assuming this is
a character. I'm assuming that mouth is the sister. You don't know.
Yeah.
That's worse.
I know why you're turning into a woman, father.
Why are there boobs, father?
It's I know 100% that there were self destructing in the helmet.
I'm going to rip it as far as you know, that was only for the suits for Mark one soldiers.
The mark, sorry, Mark two soldiers did not explode.
I'm just rip it off.
Do whatever.
Yeah, just do a normal strength roll and I'll do a contested strength roll.
Oh, holy shit.
It doesn't matter.
You did a strength save, but I think the modifier would be the same, right?
Yeah, okay. Anyway, you basically put your claws on the helmet as you just rip it off.
Only part of the helmet comes off, but the wiser just falls down as Malfa's right now.
What you see in front of you is a horrifying sight of your sister's face, but the eyes are like
stitched together to the side of it and the mouth is like sealed shut, like a soared shut essentially.
And you see inside the eyes, there is nothing.
At this point, the thing inside is probably not even human.
I mean, it's not human, but it's not even conscious.
I'm going to take whatever helmet chunk I have, give it to Bob or throw that bomb and be like,
figure something out with it.
Okay, the helmet chunk lands right at the feet.
Yeah, it's like probably you throw it, assuming that I'm going to catch it, but it's like,
it's like a wall or something and Bob is like nothing more than a tin can at this point.
Yeah, he's just standing still.
It's going to be Chloe's turn.
She looks at you, Roma, as she leaps to attack you.
One, two,
four is this not going to hit?
Second is not going to hit.
So as she leaps to attack you,
Roma, you just fucking don't care.
She's just hitting you.
It doesn't matter to you.
Right now, what you're trying to do is survive.
It's going to be Ben's turn as he looks at Daniel and he goes, what are you doing?
We don't need to get into this mess.
Daniel, you can't, we can't defy the Marines.
You know that better than I do.
As he is going to ignore you, Baptiste, and try to grab Daniel again.
This time he is grabbing.
Let me step so I'm no longer in the...
Why?
Oh, did you restart?
When were you?
I think you were before...
No.
I think you were after Ben maybe, I don't know.
I'll add you there.
AC is there.
I'm going to change your thing to that then.
Update combatant.
Initiative value would be 17 then.
I think it's right up.
Wait.
Where did I bring these to have my news?
Did you do, were you just not in combat?
I was in the order.
He's after Chloe.
Okay.
I'm going to just update that there instead of like sitting around, thinking about it.
No, he's after, yeah.
No, he's after Malfitz.
He's right after Malfitz because if you look in the thing, he did a knockout strike right after Malfitz.
Did he?
See, no, but that was before he'd be expected.
Yeah, that was opportunity, yeah.
I'm going to say that before Ben moves in, he says that, that he's what you're going to do,
because Ben is going to move in.
It's up to you what you do.
Can you have did with Ben did in I can just go off of that?
Yeah, okay.
I can just do that then.
Daniel fails the contested role.
He grabs Ben grabs Daniel as he's trying to dash away.
To here.
Do an opportunity.
Yes.
Yes, yes, he is, he cannot move and Ben at this point would not try to like
do anything.
Are you killing him?
Hell yeah, kill him.
Are you going to kill it?
No, I'm asking are you going to kill him or no?
No, you can do not lead the list fine.
Yeah.
No, he's trying to save Daniel because he cares.
Maybe a bit too much.
Close into a rage.
The thing the robot thing is going to fight Ben because it's why his the robot's
executive you need to understand the robots objective is to get the Lunarians first and then kill you.
Yeah, but they need to be alive, right?
So if Ben tries to kill Baptiste and maybe I don't know.
Go away, go away, go ahead, but do the damage.
Not these.
That's not going to kill him.
I'm just asking in advance.
You know, okay, yeah, it's not going to kill him, but yeah.
It's really hard.
Okay, you as Ben is taking him away, you land another one of your,
what do you call it, the actual arms just punches straight through Daniel,
right through his chest, but those are astral.
It does do like internal damage, but not like any physical damage.
I that cleaves through.
Mountain mouth is a certain.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thunderbird.
Bird time.
Okay, that was the opportunity.
Okay, yeah, go ahead.
Either I can go full form on this bike,
or I can just go for damage right now.
Let's just go full form.
Okay, flame mode on the flame flares as your body starts to get heavier and heavier,
as your muscle starts to grow.
What are you doing?
The arms also start to take on like a fiery.
Yeah, yeah, the the arms starts to grow red instead of like just black like white.
Okay, that's a bonus action, by the way, so you can only do one thing.
That's one punch, but I can also just do this, which might be a better choice.
Remember long range, if you're doing anything, long range, that's not gonna,
that's just gonna kill anyone you're trying to.
I'm not.
Yeah.
It's something to make this bike last longer.
One punch isn't gonna really help anybody right now.
As you take out one of the capsules in your bag and just inject yourself with it,
it's gonna heal 10 plus as your body starts to heal along with your flames helping your body grow.
Now if it's a short turn.
Okay, to Chloe.
Don't run away, you placed me.
As Daniel's been taken away by Ben, he says that.
You're not even enough opponent to worry about anymore.
I'm not letting me go.
It's Malfus.
It's your turn.
Yeah, let me do that.
Sorry.
I was looking at something.
There you go.
You go bird.
Yeah, that doesn't hit.
As you strike with one of your talents, it basically just deflects off of the armor.
Again.
Oh yeah, that's it.
Yeah, bonus action you've already done.
Okay, as you fly straight up 50 feet, the thing just again, completely eyes open.
This turns his head to look, look at you.
And it's going to be another marine making a move.
This one.
What?
Yeah, the wiser was not the, it was just to hide the face inside.
Who?
Malfus recognizes the face.
Why do you think I want to keep it alone?
Yeah.
The first class marine is now going to get on to the rope that it fired and it's going to
cross over to the mast again and it's going to
do nothing because that's his movement he can't do anything else.
It doesn't have one of the guns.
Yeah.
It's the
Wonderland's turn.
Wonderland's going to again fly up 50 feet and it's going to
do the unarmed strike again.
With Flurry of Blows.
It's going to keep attacking
until he hits it hits.
Sorry.
No, one one hits.
Has this one?
Why is it 13 again?
The match damage was the radiant one.
That's crazy.
Yeah, as it drives through which you as you try to move away, maneuver your way around it,
the last one hits right at your face as it puts you down.
Make it extra easy.
Yeah, it's going to be able to you would be able to stabilize yourself as one of the hits land
on you.
Again, you feel the strange energy buzzing off of like the armors, like fists,
that collapses. Just now you recognize your strength as like blocking
sheer damage, but this energy that you're feeling out of is something new that you haven't
felt before.
Yeah, there you go.
It's going to be its turn.
That's 13.
The blushing pass.
Yeah, the blushing was one.
The blushing was six because it kind of plus five two.
Yes.
Oh, it's not having the plus five, I think.
Is it seven plus six?
No, it's not.
Why is it not doing that?
I mean,
why?
It's not doing that.
I don't think the bonus gets half.
Does it?
I think the die only gets half.
No, it's the complete blushing damage.
Oh, I see.
So I actually the the one before needs to be added to then.
Let me check.
Well, we probably keep that one when I go back to a normal,
because that one would be added to my normal form.
Oh, yeah, yeah, true, true, true.
Okay, so I'm going to just just remember that.
What did I have?
I haven't scored up that far.
We'll see where that was.
What was the last hit you did?
In your what was the health
at before the transformation?
20.
20 out of 25.
20 out of 30.
30.
So that was 10.
I think plus five, right?
So you just add plus five
to when you return to normal form.
Look at this time again, do plus five
to the current health.
Can you?
I don't think you can actually.
Let me do that for you.
There you go.
Now it's plus six.
God damn it.
That I can chase my own health.
Oh, well.
All right, Roma, Searsher and both of the things that were
in your range have flown away.
You have one opportunity to attack on
mouthfuls sister, which you don't know mouthfuls sister.
And I'm swinging.
Yes, wing opportunity attack.
Right.
It's gonna be a normal pain attack.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's not gonna happen.
As you try to swing at it,
it just bursts up with like a sheer force
that you just cannot catch up to it.
The other Marines will now.
Oh, yeah, that's your turn.
Sorry.
Your turn.
Go ahead.
I told this bitch she's gonna die.
So yeah.
Killer bitch.
Yeah, you already know it.
We're gonna pop the friends you will
three regularly.
She'll die.
Oh, right.
Pain attack.
Doesn't hit.
There you go.
It just works like that.
Sometimes.
You could just move the bits of your flanking.
That's fine.
I mean, it doesn't matter.
He's doing it with the advantage anyway.
17.
It's yeah, sure.
I think in character, Roma doesn't care.
As one of your hits land as first misses,
the second one lands, she gets hit right in the face.
And again, the same thing happens to her face turns
all the way back as she is still kind of moving.
Soon after though, she just falls down and it's not getting up.
These things are now going to fire a cannon at you.
They're gonna shoot at.
They're gonna shoot at us because like that's a one big area with
it's there. They're gonna target.
They're gonna target the Lunarians.
Well, I'm in there.
Yeah, the last position that they were on were near this and this.
So they're just gonna fight fire there because in between you guys have moved.
So they're just gonna fire there.
Let me do a roll.
Chloe rolled the 49.
No, it was the.
The first shot fires toward.
Let me see.
What is half of 49?
20.
24 and a half.
25.
Tees.
You're gonna.
You don't round down.
You round up.
Yeah, exactly.
Baptiste, you go unconscious.
What?
No, it's here.
They just land here.
The cannon lands here.
You could try to do a deck safe.
I'll give you that, but the thing is pointed towards you.
It's not gonna help any more.
You can do a deck safe.
DC is pretty high.
That's why I was like.
Cannons usually do not have like deck saves associated.
But I'll give you deck saves.
Yeah.
I just.
Sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can.
I can understand that.
Go ahead, make deck saves.
Everyone in the vicinity, which is Chloe.
Chloe can't make a deck save because she's incapacitated.
Bob, sorry, not Bob is pretty far away.
Roma and mouth.
Sorry, Baptiste, you do make deck saves.
No, I failed that.
And it's do have a range of 10 to roll, but.
I'll do that.
Let me do that.
The cannon.
It's a D20 plus six to hit.
Okay, I'll roll that then.
It's padded in one target.
It's nearly.
I'm just reading what the cannon says.
Okay, can block.
It is one target.
Okay, they're going to target you.
Roma, you don't have to do that.
I'm going to go by the rules that what do any plus.
What's the damage?
What's the damage, correct?
No, no, I'm checking. Yeah, it deta.
I was right.
One D20 plus six, right?
Okay, let's do that.
I actually rolled the cannon damage the same way with
Malfus and Bob's team before.
So that's why I was going with the same rules, but yeah.
Yeah, 15.
It missed.
So the cannon goes
through right through you.
Lodge itself in the like the crate as it just falls down near the area where like
Malfus like burst through below that area.
And the explosion goes off.
Yeah, the explosion goes off below deck instead of hitting
you, Baptiste.
I'm going to restore your HP, sorry.
And we move on from the first marine who is about to get a lecture from his
superiors.
The second guy we're going to is going to fire the cannon around here.
It's going to damage the ship.
So the ship damage would be at this point 49 plus 39.
It's going to be 88.
Okay, you have to also understand the ship was damaged once with the cannon.
Two cannons have also fired.
So it's even more damaged.
You have ships like have about 100 HP or so.
Like how is the ship?
Ship.
The ship.
No, the ship is pretty much very
for like reinforced by the spiders.
Oh, nice.
So it shouldn't be that easy to go down.
This marine is going to do the same and move
through the ropes to the mast again.
That's going to be its turn.
And the last, I think that's all three Marines.
It's Daniel's turn and he will try to get out the grapple with a strength check.
And he's going to fail.
It's the
Marine that's commanding these officers.
He will just say,
forget the cannons, get them.
And that's going to be his command and that's going to be in a fish turn.
Boss at this point is looking at Daniel and at the last thing he said,
he's not very happy with Daniel.
So he will command the rest of the officers to take care of the spiders first
and then capture the Lunarians.
And not not the agent wonderland that's fighting you, not her, just the rest.
And he will do his
and he's going to kick the share out of
Ben.
Assort the not the legendary action sorry, normal action.
It's going to hit.
Image.
Go as he jump space walk up, sorry,
fucking sky rocks across the ship and just lands like a foot straight into Ben's face.
It's going to be his turn.
This suit of arc bar is going to dash.
That's going to be his turn.
Bob is your turn now.
Oh boy.
So this guy is like fully in shock right now and like hopeless.
Currently doesn't have any hope for life for himself or anything.
So he doesn't know what to do.
But he was the guy that said that his mother died.
He's just going to make one last attempt with all of his will because his will is pretty broken.
So he's going to just try one last time to he saw Boro do the skywalk and he saw
a veil do the skywalk as well.
So in his mind he thinks that Boro is probably also a developer user.
Bob wants to kill Boro.
So Bob wants to kill Boro and the only way he knows how to kill developer users is probably
like putting them under water, like putting them in the water.
He's going to use Boro as a last attempt because he doesn't know what to do otherwise.
And he's going to use Boro here goes a spill and he's going to go all out with this move.
So he's going to give his nine his portantium in the chat there.
Yeah, portant's 17 and nine.
He's going to give nine to Boro.
Boro feels this.
I'm going to have a denail you.
Yeah, Boro feels the safe.
You magically twist space around creature you see within the range.
The targets must succeed a constant using through the if the target's heliportar tune unoccupied space.
If you're choice, I can see within the range.
The children's space must be on a surface or in a liquid that can support the target without the target having to squeeze.
Okay.
What can you explain to me how your work works liquid work.
Sorry, how your vortex work works.
So similar thing to the misty step but he developed it further so that it can target not himself but another person.
So the equipment that he uses to do the misty step he just throws shoots them into another person
and gives the coordinates so that person is being teleported in that location.
Okay, so what you see Bob just chucks something that lands on the side of world but for a few seconds.
The outcome changes and it actually hits Boro as Bob sends another object into the ocean right here.
And Boro is enveloped by this blue warping energy as he just collapses right in front and just reappears here.
Boro at this point is very confused but he is drowning because he spawn in the water instead of outside.
That's gonna be your turn.
Bob.
I mean there's nothing else that's the only thing that is Bob's in most mine right now so end of turn.
Okay, you Bob at the edge of your from the corner of you I can see the bubbles coming up out of the ocean as you end your turn.
As you end your turn Boro is going to take his legendary action to Saru.
Bob said he's gonna kill someone.
And you see a streak jumping out of the ocean as he just stabilizes near like this sky and he just looks at you as he goes.
I guess you were just as pointless as I thought you were machine man.
No matter you will die here.
That's gonna be his legendary action and then this marine is going to dash again here
toward the rope.
That's gonna be his turn.
That was for a user yes.
Dan so he's just inherently strong what the hell.
There's those techniques that oil balls will use you as too late.
Yeah, I mean Saru doesn't have anything to do devil fruits.
Yeah.
They're hockey.
All right, I'm gonna skip over Chloe.
Baptiste your turn.
Where am I?
The thing is in the air by the way these two are like fighting in the air 50 feet above.
I can't even quite I can't get up.
Exactly.
Sure.
Want me to come down.
You can you can use step of the wind ash.
No, I don't want to waste the key point on that.
All right, I'll go down 20 feet.
I have my flame on both so let's just take care of these two.
Yeah, let's just start swinging.
Bob can you sorry Bob, Malfus, Roma and Baptiste can you give me a perception check?
It's gonna hit who you do you want to hit the first one.
Who looks weaker?
No one's weaker because they haven't been hit once.
But the but you know that this is like the first marine like special grade marine and this is
like just a normal recruit. You know that already.
I'll hit the recruit first.
All right.
You want to do the perception thing first or you want me to roll?
Yeah, yeah, perception.
No, no, just just roll for damage.
I'll tell you what happens on perception.
Nine.
I can see it.
10, 14.
It's not private.
I think it's GM maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, so that's what you're going to turn it to public.
Okay.
It's 16 damage to the recruit because I keep him up.
Yeah, that's going to keep him up.
As you like, one punch on the recruit, the area on the mast is pretty unstable.
He is going to fall down and grapple on to like the rod essentially.
He also gets 1, 4 fire.
So two fire damage.
Hmm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
What do you want to do with your bonus?
You said he's hanging.
He's hanging.
You have a advantage on the next one.
On him, but if you want to attack the other guy, then you can attack him first.
I'll try to get rid of the first one.
Let me check if that hits him or not.
That doesn't hit.
You try to like basically kick him off, but he just through the strength of the armor,
he just latches on to the mast.
This is going to be your turn, right?
Yeah, I'm not going to worry about the area blows through.
At this point, you start to see daylight,
like the sun rising from this angle.
And weirdly, there's like no birds, no animals, nothing you can notice outside.
Who are the people who noticed this is that taste and mouthless.
Yeah.
At this angle, you just feel something strange.
Know what is happening.
There is no wind resistance either.
And all the cannon fodder that you saw go off, there is no smoke of it either.
So it feels kind of weird to you.
Baptiste, you just notice there's no presence of any animals around at all.
Okay, it's going to be, it was a full moon before when it happened and now the sun's coming up.
I was just asking because if it's a full moon, that means from a cave, it's too long for it.
No, he hasn't locked so long yet.
Yeah, you don't know the area.
It's Ben's turn as he goes.
I guess there's no point resisting.
He's going to keep us down.
No, because of what you said.
He's going to push his Daniel down and he's going to look at was and he has nothing else to do
honestly.
So he's going to just use an improvised weapon around somewhere lying here and
like creates and he's just going to throw those creates Adam.
Improvised weapon.
Burr.
Improvised weapons.
I think the role for a hit is the same, right?
Just the damage is different.
Yeah, that's going to miss.
He just throws one of the like creates at was as the crates just goes through.
Question.
Bob's owl search the entire ship.
Correct.
Serpent well.
Yeah.
Okay.
So like they're not on the ship.
They're just not on the ship.
As far as Bob knows, they're not on the ship.
He has not relayed this information to any of you yet.
So you don't know about that.
Malthus is your turn.
You're flying in the air, fighting off this thing that looks like your sister,
but you don't know if it is at this point.
The moment we have the fight people will listen to react.
It's all up to you.
Yeah.
I'm going.
Well, I'm just going to hit.
So I can do it at this point.
You know, yeah.
That's not going to hit.
20.
Was boarding all 20.
That went to a two that went to 12.
Yeah, that's not going to hit as soon as you again.
The same thing happens.
You land one hit and it just does not penetrate the armor.
That's good.
Same goes now.
You're still flying in the air.
This marine will try to get
himself over while you miss all your attacks.
That's going to be it's turned.
The thing at this point will attack you.
Goflar, you're blows.
Okay.
The first one hits.
The second one hits.
The third one hits.
Okay.
So the first one is two.
Right?
And the second one is.
Wait, how is it even possible to
5 plus 5 minus 3.
Wait, what?
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't targeting you, sorry.
So it's going to be 13 minus 5 that's 7.
And then 13 minus 5 that's 7.
13, 15 minus 5 that's 10.
7, 7, 10 is going to be 24.
It's going to knock you out of your form.
And then you take plus 5 then minus 2.
So that's 3.
Just add 3 damage.
Yeah.
As you're not out of your transformation as you're falling down,
can you make a deck safe?
Yeah, you're able to stabilize yourself as you're like
starting to fall down as you transform back.
But you just flap your wings and get up.
Getting ready to take care of
whatever you're facing right now.
Roma, it's your turn.
All right.
How tall is this mask?
This mask is about 20 feet.
So 20 feet, right?
You can jump, I think.
If you have a good enough strength, you can just jump that distance.
Let me check.
You have plus 2, right?
So, um, jump distance.
Elkulation.
What is your strength score?
15, right?
Yeah.
15.
How tall are you?
8, right?
Yeah.
8 foot.
Okay.
You can move 15 feet up.
I'll say you should be able to grab and get yourself up by 15 feet jump.
Okay.
What do I got to roll just nothing?
Okay, well, then, should jump is just jump.
Yeah.
I'm going to jump my ass up here.
And then.
Okay, so I'm going to push the one standing for my left off the mask.
Push is a athletics, right?
I see, I don't know.
I thought it was.
Okay.
Do you roll right?
Yeah, yeah.
Just click on athletics.
Okay.
Let me check against.
Okay, I can either make an acrobatics or athletics.
Uh, I'm going to make athletics.
You're going to miss athletics.
Okay.
So, as you push him off, this suit is going to fall five feet here.
And 15 feet damage should be one d6, right?
Oh, one d6.
And then I'll do another one d6 and half that.
Two, two, three.
So he's going to take three damage as it falls down.
Uh, I don't think I can do anything else.
All right.
Um, it's your turn.
I mean, you can use your bonus to transform.
Yeah, I'm still at full health.
Like they have nobody to hit me.
Yeah.
I mean, you don't want to die in your first head.
But it's up to you.
Uh, we can move on.
Miss your turn.
Uh, the next few Marines are going to make their way off the rope.
Again, to the top of the mast.
Uh, and this one is going to dash toward this.
Uh, that's going to be its turn.
Daniel, at this point, is very single,
minded and just going to run towards
Baptiste.
He's going to use his dash as well and get on top of
the mast just behind Baptiste.
But that's going to be end of his turn.
These.
Hold on.
Time out.
He passed through three different people who would have had an impact
of opportunity and landed in an area where there is no, there are no people here.
Mouth is.
He just.
Now they're in the air.
Yeah.
They're in the air.
That's why.
Um,
uh, this one is going to slam you to the ground
in an attempt to get you.
Out of his side, 20 is going to hit.
Uh, let's do the damage.
This one.
Uh, it's going to be nine.
Can you make a, uh, deck safe?
Just to see if you can stabilize yourself on top of the mast.
Because there's like a lot of people on here.
Actually, I want to make some or all too.
Yeah.
Okay.
As that I hits you, you plant yourself on top of the mast as the weight on top of this
mast is now starting to collapse.
Baptiste, I will give you one reaction.
If you want to save Roma, you can make a con save.
Can I'm sorry, not con.
Fucking dexive.
I don't think.
You want to roll con, roll con.
Okay, that 20.
Um, uh, so you grab onto Roma, the weight is kind of pulling you down,
but you muster up all your arms that are around you and just pull Roma up as you fly
10 feet, uh, our basically 10 feet above the mast that is now collapsing.
This marine is just going to fall in the water and disappear.
This marine is also going to fall into the water, disappear.
This marine is going to fall on the ground.
Roll one, the six.
Uh, so five plus two is going to be seven.
Uh, this one's going to fall to the ground.
There is no mast.
Daniel is also going to fall to the ground.
And that will might one D.
Roll one D.
Uh, so that's going to do three, three plus two.
Oh, barely.
Okay, you fall through the ground, but he's still conscious here.
Let's say it here and this one falls to the ground.
And takes, I'll say this is same damage as this marine is going to take the same.
I want to roll again and again for the same fucking shit.
Uh, all right, it's Wasis churn.
As he's seeing all the Marines being picked off, he has a decision to make.
Does he prioritize you, Bob?
Or does he prioritize taking care of the, um,
he already told his troops to go after the spider.
So if he, if he backs now, he's gonna sound like a pussy.
And he's a marine either doesn't care.
I'm going to make a wisdom save just in case.
He is a pussy.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to say.
Uh, 20, he fails.
He succeeds as a wisdom.
So he will go into, he will go to try to capture
Baptiste instead of engaging with Bob.
Um, he's gonna rule dash.
Because you're a fucking you're not, you're sure no challenge in that.
Uh, there's another one here.
Yeah, but the, uh, the Wonderland is taking care of that.
12 does not hit.
As it tries to strike to rule you, it will just basically like
miss you and go ahead.
Uh,
is T
suits turn.
Which is now that okay.
Um, let me just remove that for the crowds then.
Uh,
make us proud Bob.
Uh, nope.
What do you know?
So, uh, yeah,
but, like, at this point, he,
he's pretty sure everybody's going to die.
I mean, not everybody.
He's pretty sure he is going to die.
And like, he sees all the fights happening in the background
or the cannons firing.
It does not care.
Like the only thing on his mind is right now.
Like, I thought,
I thought they were not going to be involved in this.
I thought they were, I changed my identity.
I changed my name.
I thought nothing I would do would actually affect them.
And now,
and now, months dead.
So he, he's pretty sure he's going to die and he wants to spend his last moments
with his mother.
So where did you set the bodies were?
Uh, the bodies were here.
Near the mast of the other side.
Bob is going to hanging from the mast essentially.
Yeah, uh,
but I was going to dash like
till over here and then miss his step to over here.
Okay, as you miss his step here,
can you do another perception for me?
Roma, at this point,
I don't know if you heard or not.
Another body is hanging off of this and that's red.
Yeah, red.
Yeah, that's what caused me to rage in the first place.
Yeah, okay.
This is what I make sure because I think you would go on for a few seconds there.
All right, Bob.
Perception, please.
Yeah, it looks to you that it's your mother
hanging off of the
where the several.
No, he doesn't think of everything.
Yeah, uh, that's going to be your turn.
Uh,
miss his step is bonus, though.
Do you want to do something?
Yes.
No, I use my action to dash.
Oh, was that that far?
Oh, yeah, it was, it was pretty far.
30 feet here and then from here.
Yeah, okay, make sense.
Do I have my action, though?
Like, uh, what's what?
What do I have?
You can use an action.
I'll give you an action if you want to use it.
Okay, if I use my action to like,
hold her, hold her face close to me and like,
hold her tight.
Do I get any advantage on perception?
If you pull her closer,
yeah, do another perception check.
Another just perception, no advantage, just perception.
Yes, okay.
Oh boy, like, come on three times.
At least, wow, yeah, he is very
satchelist.
Yeah, yeah, the, uh, the, the tears don't come out,
but Bob is shattered.
Yeah, um, yeah.
Uh, Chloe's gone, uh, Matties.
You're flying up in the air.
You're still holding Roma.
What do you want to do?
Was is the right in front of you, by the way.
Is just a Roma on top of the, um, action.
Uh, no, you can just let him go. That's a reaction, Elsa.
What?
The windows on the ground, like,
Rome since he fell off the mask.
Yes, yes.
I'm dropping Roma on top of him.
Okay, this is, this is, this is,
this is ranged.
Just so you know, 10 feet up.
Oh, no.
Uh, wait.
Do Roma do people's elbow?
Shit.
Moonsolk.
That's what I'm saying.
All right, you're just gonna be,
500 pounds ball of fur.
Just fucking canon ball and on top of it.
That's okay.
Roma, you're gonna do 24 damage to Daniel.
And yeah, basically, like, every bone in his body just shatters at that point as he just
lies dead right beneath you.
Uh, Baptiste, it's your action and bonus.
What do you want to do?
Um.
Um, I'm really like it if Laura wasn't where he is,
but he's going to be there.
So I'll just move down my pants and just try to get some hits in.
And fails.
As you're just desperately trying to punch world, every hit just misses, misses.
You remember you are having flashbacks to what happened back in spirit clothes.
Shit.
I was landing hit that spirit clip, okay?
Yeah, but you have like kind of a stigma in your head about what happened there.
I remember he bitch slapped you and just fucking almost killed you.
Is that it?
No flurry of blows?
I'm not gonna flurry up.
All right.
It's Ben's turn and Ben will at this point dash
toward Roma because Daniel from his angle seems to be dead.
And that's gonna be his turn.
And you see, you, you, you dropped a 500 pound
being on something.
He's gonna see that.
At least he's gonna hear that.
He walks up behind you, Roma, this shadow now covering you entirely
as you hear thumps just walking towards you.
Malthus, your turn.
Hello.
I need somebody.
Yeah, that's gonna hit.
Wait, why, why a bit of anage?
'Cause shock and graphic gas will advantage on metallic shapes.
Okay.
I forgot to tell you this is not exactly metal.
Whoa, okay.
I can show you the character should, if you're doubting me.
They are armors, but this one's different.
This is more like covering parts of the body,
not like complete armor, like tech,
not like actual tech armor.
It's just covering part of the body.
14 plus five, yeah, that's gonna hit.
To the damage.
Wait, did I give me one second?
Ah shit.
I accidentally put it in the immunities.
Oh, I'll just do normal damage.
39.
That's why I was showing zero for me.
I was like, why is it zero?
But yeah, it's gonna take full damage
of all the like electric jolt that are coming out of your fingers.
Fingergone.
Bam, bam, bam.
Okay.
This armor is going to now get up from prone.
And...
Sometimes strike, thank you very much.
What?
Oh yeah, you do, you do, fuck.
Yeah, I forgot.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
It's not gonna hit.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, so the Jolt's land,
you try to swing at it,
but it just ducks underneath you
as he flies and circles around.
It's gonna be this person's turn
is going to run towards Roma
and do the thrusters land this time
with a 15 feet line throwing Roma five feet behind.
Roma, can you make a deck save?
She said five feet behind when they go...
So basically,
he starts from here,
it will take you 15 feet here with him.
Right, she slams into you as the thrusters
go full force right into you.
Deck save is 10, so we're gonna take
a show full damage. Let me do that.
No more on your charge.
But the reason I'm asking is you said
Daniel or whatever
been whoever the big fuck was,
literally standing right behind you.
So I just slam right into him.
Yeah, so you slam right into him
and he's gonna take the same amount of damage as you.
It's gonna be nine to you.
So, Fort,
why is it Fort? Do you have bludgeoning resistance?
Oh, you're in rage. You're in rage.
Yes, sorry, I forgot.
And Ben is going to take
nine as you both are like thrown into each other as this
marine is just shoving you aside with the thrusters.
And it's project of modern lands turn.
And at this point,
it is going to use
wellness of body.
To heal whatever damage it took.
I mean, it's his protocols. It has to follow.
And
this time it's going to use an armed shriek.
It's cautiously
trying to knock you out without killing you.
So it's just gonna do once.
It's gonna be nine minus five.
Just four.
Can you make another deck save?
Yes.
22.
Yeah, you should be able to stabilize yourself as one of the hits land.
This time you do feel like
it was kind of held back. It's trying to not kill you.
This marine is the rope is gone because the mass is broken.
So this marine is going to
shoot at you, Baptiste. Let me see if he can actually.
Yeah, he can.
Let me see.
Okay.
That misses. Okay.
Um.
Wait, why is it his turn and not
Rome is.
Rome, sorry, I missed your turn.
So you could go ahead.
No, you're okay.
So I got Bob, where I got in behind me.
Yeah.
So I'm just going to try to fucking.
Is there a way I can grab this guy in front of me?
Spin him around, throw him into fucking.
Is it been?
Who the fuck is a big dude?
Right.
Like you know what I'm saying?
Take the soldier in front of me.
Yeah.
Like spin and throw to have him back in the bin and.
Okay.
Who a strength check?
I'll do a contested strength check for the armor guy.
Is it staving throwers in just straight check?
I just click on SDR on your sheet.
That's it.
Yeah, you're going to succeed.
You grab him.
It resists, tries to resist you, but you just grab him and just throw him off
back to the side.
Can you just do it, attacker?
Or just to see if you throw him on him or somewhere else?
Like just a normal attack roll?
I don't just use your fucking skillet.
Uh, that is going to hit Ben.
Okay.
So you move around, you grapple this dude.
You throw him at Ben.
I'm going to do another improvised damage to Ben.
Well, I was hoping he would be heavy enough
where it tall bend,
cross bend and stumble.
And since he's only five feet from the fucking edge,
like you fall off the edge of the ship.
Okay, I'll make a deck save
to see if he can stabilize himself or fall off.
Yep.
Okay, so you hurl this thing at him as Ben is just taking a back by this
and he's going to fall off the ship,
but he's still going to grab onto the rails.
As this Marine is going to be prone now,
uh, this Marine shot to shot, this Marine will wake up
as he sees what is happening here.
He will target U-Roma and attack you with the gun.
Yeah, he misses.
All right.
Next is Daniel, who is dead.
And sorry, Daniel.
And this one is going to run up to U-Roma
and slam.
And do the damage.
It's going to be six.
Hey, go.
And it's going to be Wasistern.
Okay.
Uh, on his turn,
there is a voice coming onto from the ship.
Enough of this finish at Was.
We've delayed our operations far too much.
You have to pray for your crimes for letting these
insects survive.
What happened on Spirit Cliffs shall not
happen again.
Got clues on your losses.
The spiders will be taken care of.
In time,
do what happened?
Do you understand me, Was?
As that order comes through the ship, uh,
was kind of at this point, this is the first time you've seen
was like kind of sweating.
And he is going to
do another.
Is it Wasistern?
Was is his marine name.
Voro was his like, uh, agent name.
Voro was, they told you, okay, if you paid attention,
they talked, the six folks always called Voro Voro.
But you know his name is Was because these guys told you that they found
a letter named for Was
by Captain, the commander that they met at their thing.
If I paid attention,
the, I was just saying, you know, it's not something, it's very subtle.
I do forget sometimes.
I probably have said Was on Voro interchangeably sometimes.
But yeah, the commander, the Commodore,
they're the same guy.
The Commodore calls him Was.
The six folks called him Voro.
Uh, he is going to use his saken strike
again on you, uptiste.
That's going to hit.
It's going to be six.
As he again flies through you,
around you here, it's going to be his turn.
Just and yourself over.
Don't make it worse on yourself.
We don't want to kill you.
Just surrender yourself and be a puppet of the government as you have been
for most of your life.
Okay, uh, Bobby's turn.
Uh, yeah, do I do any precision checks or not?
Uh, I mean, you've tried twice.
I don't think there's any point doing any more.
Right.
And uh, uh, in the perception,
just, uh, what did I learn from the checks?
Like, what is my mom and, I think it's you do, you think like it is your mother?
Okay.
I mean, she is actually that.
I did not learn that.
I mean, I did not confirm that she was actually dead or not, right?
Because like, Bob still probably has a little bit of hope
that it's she might not know.
Uh, you can try to do an insight.
Uh, I want to do, uh, the check and like,
if Bob thinks that she's alive, she,
he's probably going to try to heal or something.
Okay, do an insight.
Okay, let's do it.
Just so you know, she was hanged by the neck off of the mast.
For a long time, you can do an insight.
I'll give you an insight.
It's not like she was just tied up.
They were not like having like a picnic.
Yeah, Bob is still like pretty broken.
He, he just cannot convince himself that she is dead.
He just, he wants to cry, but he can't cry.
He's just screaming at the top of his lungs.
Uh, can you do, do you want to do something?
Or is that it?
Fire-a-canon.
Yeah, that's what I was going for.
And like, there's almost literally nothing that he can exactly do right now.
So he sees the cannon.
He sees Voril and he's going to try to shoot the cannon as long as he lives.
Can a fire malaiser?
All right.
Can you make a 1D20+6 roll?
Oh my god.
I'm not going to be that one.
No, I can't.
So you try to angle the cannon toward
boss, but it's just not moving. It's just stuck as you try to fire it.
It just misses him completely.
And that's going to be your turn unless you want him to do a bonus action.
If you have one.
Nope.
Bonus action.
Try again.
No, as I can be a bonus action.
Why do I have Chloe here?
So, uh, about to use your turn.
9 HP in a dream.
Malthus is one on one that I can't really move about.
Let's throw it off right.
Give me a good one.
I'm assuming you both are still in the air.
That's Malthus.
No, no, you both are still in the air because you didn't go down.
Voro didn't go down.
He has been just skywalking and kicking you.
Yeah.
But you just dropped me like you say here.
That's going to hit though.
The bird's forced damage.
And you're still playing 1D4 fire.
That's a lot of fucking damage, bro.
But that's not a lot of damage.
All right.
Do another one.
It's going to miss.
It was a 19 minute row.
Do you want to do 30?
Oh, blows are no.
Do one or more.
Oh.
You might as well go grab a tail punch.
12 is not going to hit.
The first one does hit and it does do a lot of damage.
So it's going to be 17.
There you go.
And 10 more.
Uh.
All right.
That's your turn.
Now, he says you try to just punch him out of the air.
I'll make another deck save to see if he stays in the air.
There you go.
Normal.
He does stay in the air.
Okay.
As he stabilizes himself with another,
so you in the air,
looks at you as it goes.
He wipes the blood off his face as he looks at you and goes.
Well, you still have your spirit.
Don't worry.
I will kill all your friends.
And that spirit will give up soon enough.
Uh, Ben is deraunting.
I'm going to just kill him.
Okay.
Malfus.
Don't you talk,
doesn't it?
Yes, he does.
I need to hit first.
Yeah, you don't hit.
Again, you try to shoot the lightning, uh,
jolt's out of your hand this time.
The thing in front of you seems prepared as it just dodges all of the
jolt's coming out of your hand.
Uh, and do an enrage.
And that doesn't hit.
The.
Do you want to change characters?
I actually feel myself.
Yeah, do you want to just want to jump in the water?
I'm joking.
Go back.
And the test suit is now going to get up from prone and it's going to flank you, Roma.
And attack you with an advantage.
Time out.
Well,
isn't, isn't standing up.
And moving would that be his entire?
No, no, uh, that's half, half movement.
It just has been.
And then it comes past your movements.
Yeah.
Okay.
It is going to head, right?
Yeah, let me do the damage.
Six, there we go.
You're only taking sixes.
What is happening?
Project Wonderland again, she's being very careful not to kill you.
And she's only going to hit you once and that hits and
it's going to be another
five.
Oh my god.
Now she's not hitting you as much.
And now she can do any damage.
Okay.
It's going to be its turn.
Roma.
Okay, question.
How far can I throw a body?
I'd say only ten feet.
Perfect.
Because that's, uh, now he's 15 feet.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I'm going to take this one here.
How do I think the one that's behind me?
Like, I'm going to grab him and same thing I did to
fucking Ben.
I'm rolling him around and fucking it cracked.
The dude standing in front of me.
Is the same guy.
The same guy is having a half of his life.
Just do a strength check.
Uh, he's not rolling good.
Yeah, that's going to be you can pick him up and throw him again.
Again, you grab him and he goes, not again.
You just hold him back on this guy.
It's going to take five feet unless he saves the deck somehow.
Oh, he critically succeeds.
He just grabs this guy and shoves him off.
And it's going to be it for your turn.
No, one last thing.
Transform.
Let me do that for you.
Uh, there you go.
Let me see.
What's your passive?
There was a passive ability that I always forget about.
Call the aura.
Okay, you have to actually trigger it though.
Okay, that's fine.
All right, this marine is going to take a shot at you again, Map Teased.
I hate how it takes 14.
What?
Like every time I transform, like everything that's favorite.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's like a token issue because I transform you.
I'll try to figure out how to like let players transform themselves.
I think that might fix it.
I'll have to check.
Um, how that works actually.
Uh, 14 does not hit you about mouth is right.
Yeah, sorry, Baptiste.
Uh, I don't think so.
Okay, this one is going to do the same.
Uh, check.
There you go.
14 again, okay, both of them try to shoot a shot and misses.
This one right in front of you, Roma,
that you try to attack is going to do the Wollslam again.
That's going to hit.
And that does five damage.
And next is World,
World's Turn, Woss's Turn.
Keep forgetting.
Um, okay.
Uh, Wolls looks just you again, Map Teased as he goes.
Just give yourself up.
Why fight?
You know what you were going to end up?
Experimented on.
Oh, spare me your nonsense.
I could not care less.
Things like you should be cage.
You're far too dangerous to roam around freely.
Only the government knows how to control.
We did.
Okay.
I see I can't make you see the truth.
So we'll just finish this off, shall we?
He's going to multi-attack, say, can strike twice.
14, 16.
That's your AC.
I don't think it hits.
All right.
Bob's turn.
Go Bob.
Painting, painting.
Just go.
Same thing.
Okay, 1D 20 plus 5.
1D 20 plus 5.
Plus 6.
Was it 6?
6, 6, 6.
Yeah, sorry, 6.
Okay.
Come on, at least, broke ones.
Okay, that's going to hit.
Was the damage 8D 10?
Sorry, not 66.
Fuck me.
8D 10.
9D 10.
All right, I'm going to do the legendary resistance.
But he's still going to take half damage.
So what you see is the cannon firing right at was.
At the point of contact, he notices the cannon coming to him using his observation hockey
and just envelops his whole hand in our movement hockey.
As the cannon just shoots at him, takes him off the sky.
Let me make a deck safe for him.
To see if he's still in the air or not.
He fails the deck safe.
Does it?
No, no, he doesn't.
Okay, 15 is good enough.
Okay, he doesn't fail the decks.
It would be 30 damage.
Yeah, it would be 30 damage.
It's still going to do damage.
The hockey.
I just asked him, just asking what was the benefit for the failed the deck safe?
He would fall.
Wait, okay.
Hmm.
Yeah.
30.1.
30.5.
So 31.
Yeah.
It fails what?
The deck safe.
No, the deck safe is 15.
Yeah.
But then the deck safe becomes half of 31, which is 15.
No, no, no, no.
I'm not deducting the damage.
Deck safe is to stabilize him in the air.
That's it.
Right.
So no, never.
Okay.
He's succeeded the safe, right?
Do I want to?
No, never mind.
If he falls off 10 feet, he will take 1d6 more if you that if that's what you're going for.
Yeah, that's not a, not that's not going to do much.
So that's what I never might.
Okay, I'm going to take off 31 from this.
Right.
I got the
like concentration to where you have the
No, no, no, no, not further have damage. Use the legendary resistance to use hockey essentially.
Sorry, I did 41 deductions.
So I'm adding plus 10.
Why do we just think isn't normally resistances are rounded down?
Legendary resistance is no rounding down or anything.
I'm just flavoring the resistance.
Yes, I mean, any kind of damage resistance aren't damage resistances.
No, no, I'm rounding up.
I'm rounding up.
Oh, okay.
It's going to be same for players and for NPCs so it doesn't matter really.
Yeah, that's why I'm saying because we have a guy who has
the resistance so I want to round it down if it's possible.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, he used his resistance and he's going to replace him.
Replanet it after your turn.
But as you end your turn, it's going to be another one of his legendary actions.
So you better be prepared.
By the way, also don't want to interrupt but asking aren't legendary
resistances like replenished on the long rest?
Yeah, I think it's only one legendary resistance.
You get multiple legendary.
Yeah, you get multiple legendary.
Wait, let me check actually.
I don't actually know.
Legendary resistance.
Okay, legendary resistance replenish on.
Yeah, long rest.
Okay, yeah, that's that's depending on the creature though.
Those some homebrews alternate rules exist.
What's the official ruining?
Single day, okay, okay, I think.
So long rest.
Yeah, I'll rule it as long rest.
He can only regain the resistance after the long rest.
Good job. After the end of your turn,
he is going to use his legendary action to take you out.
Because at this point you see the mask that he's wearing.
Peace of the mask just falls off like a portion of it.
That piece you see for the first time from the right side where you see the scar
on his eye going right through his face and you see under the mask he has no skin
above his teeth.
There's no skin above that and just his jaw is completely open.
As he looks at you, Bob, he's just fucking too honest to his life.
You will pay for this.
And he's going to burn his
legendary action and do his piercing fist at Bob.
You get an opportunity attack.
What?
He's moving forward.
Do an opportunity.
So as he just dashes towards you,
he slams down right behind you and this whole area is just caved in.
As the dust settles, he looks straight at you.
Oh, you're sure enough done that.
Stay strong, Bob. I can't get there.
Matt, this is your turn.
Bob's face is completely blank.
All this, the whole fight, his face is completely blank.
He's just a robot at this point.
But here he was.
No robot.
Yeah.
No, he was a cyborg.
Excuse me.
What's the difference?
Don't you call me a clanker?
Okay?
He's not a planker.
All right, Bob, this is your turn.
You can use step of the wind to get to him.
I'm not wasting two point on that.
I mean, completely honest.
Step of the wind.
Yeah, two more.
Yeah.
You can use dash.
Even dash, we know only the 40 feet behind and I still can't get up there.
Do we be on the edge?
Wouldn't you?
Yeah, but I can't attack.
So let me just be pointless to go over there right now.
I mean, dash gives you 30 more, right?
So 40 plus 40 gives you 80.
It doubles my
speed.
Yeah.
I fly speed is half of my walks.
Oh, yeah, yeah, 40.
Okay.
Yeah, that's true.
So we're just going to try to take out all these
marines over here.
All right.
Which one?
Oh, okay.
Get the flake.
Do the advantage.
You fly over, land behind the marine.
Yeah.
20.
I'm zoomed hits.
Yeah.
Bring my damage and then the one deep pork fire.
So 18 plus 20, yeah.
Is he still up?
You still up, yeah.
Yeah.
This 17.
That's going to be 17 and the one above us.
20.
One in 17. Yeah, that's going to kill him.
So you basically slam with both your astral fists right through
and with your actual like fist, you just punch the head off with the helmet,
the head of the guy actually just goes off and he dies.
Very, very sad.
Not anything.
When I threw him off the edge.
Yeah.
Did you not pay an attention?
I took one of the fucking.
No, you get that.
I think Ben with devil fruit users started.
He's not a devil fruit user, but he's very heavy and with the arm, he cannot swim.
Okay.
Memphis, you're turned.
Roma, you can use that arm.
He sunk into the ocean.
Doesn't hit again, the bolts, the same thing.
She just dodges it and the same thing again.
Subconsciously, you're trying to hit it, but every time you see the face, you're holding back.
Every time you try to hit it, you just hold back.
And you can do nothing else.
This is going to see that the guy in front of him explodes and he's going to duel slam you.
Baptiste.
20 hits.
And through the damage.
Max damage, of course.
There's five more damage to you, but Baptiste said it slams into you with his fists.
It's going to be the thing, Stern, the thing is going to.
Notice that
Voss is in danger, so it's just going to disengage with you. Where is it? Step of the wind.
Let me use that.
Step of the wind, disengage, then move.
It's 50 fleet flying here.
It's more proficient in flying than actually walking, so that's something.
And can it do anything else other than that?
You did not hit him again, right?
Oh, you did not, but it's still going to heal to the max.
HP. Actually, this is a bonus action, so it can't.
Okay, that's going to be its turn, actually.
Disengage, yeah, it's going to be.
50 feet above.
The same height as Baptiste, sorry, Malthus.
Rommas, your turn.
So I got this dude right here, 10 feet.
I'm going to turn to Baptiste and be like, you got the one in front of you?
I'm fine.
I look at you.
You're big enough going.
I just want to make, but I'm not though.
Like keep putting me underneath them.
This one here, I'm going to take him and I'm just going to throw him off the edge.
No, what?
Doing a shower of which is athletics.
Come on.
Yeah, we should be able to do that unless I save this somehow.
Yeah, you should be able to throw him off.
As you just grab this dude and just throw him off the side of the ship, he goes down and he's
going to die.
Do you do have a bonus action if you want to use it?
I don't know if you.
Or have their speed as halfed.
Okay, 10 feet.
I mean, you can choose or not.
Actually, he's going to affect this guy right here.
Baptiste is about to kill him.
I ain't worried.
Am I?
It's only his speed though.
He's not flanking him.
I'm not flanking him.
I'm within five feet.
Oh, you are.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Okay, you're flanking him.
Okay.
So you're not popping that?
Okay, go ahead.
What the fuck is this thing?
What is this?
It's something but I don't know.
What is this green thing?
Oh, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
I don't know how you can do that, but it's fine.
Right, it's going to be this Marines turn as he sees you and
was fighting here.
He's going to shoot at you, Bob.
Are they really fighting?
No, it's bosses.
Yeah, Mrs.
Uh, it's was a stern.
He looks at your Bob and just says,
Oh, why couldn't you just sit still and die?
I have to do the same thing that I did to your dear mother.
Oh, that's f*ck.
Uh.
Both are going to head, right?
Yeah.
No, no, no.
I was going to say, uh, the first one he is trying to try to
uh, do silvery bars because it's succeeded in stacking him.
Okay, do silvery bars.
I knew that's a sec.
Uh, so he needs to do it again.
Uh, let me cast it.
Okay.
Honestly, the second world.
It's a plus nine.
Uh, yeah, I know.
Yeah, he's going to miss the first one.
Okay.
Just roll the, yeah.
No, Bob.
I'm going to say 14 in.
How are there so many two very bars?
What what's going on?
No, not 14, 17.
There you go.
He smacks at you once and then a bunch of wines come out of your body like metal
wines and it just stops him as he
directs the second punch away from you.
But the first one definitely lands and hits you right in the guts.
Right back.
Uh, Bob, it's your turn.
Yes, uh, so here is what I want to do.
Uh, in the, uh, definition of cyborg, uh, description of cyborg, it says,
I am since I'm like a being made of metal or something, whatever.
I count as one size larger when attempting to a grapple, shove or push an object.
So how big is borrow?
What's about your height but a little bigger?
Okay, but is it like medium size?
Medium, I would say one P standard sees medium like Roma is huge, a large and Roma and up are large
and huge.
So it's definitely smaller than one size larger than him.
So I get advantage in trying to grapple or shove him, right?
Sure.
Okay.
Uh, I want, uh, and how much would my movement be if I, uh, grapple?
It would be half my distance, right?
Yes.
So here's what I want to do.
I want to grapple this guy.
If I succeed, I want to like jump with him under the water.
No, Bob.
It's going to suicide.
Yes, I don't care.
This guy killed my mom.
What do you mean?
So is it like an opposed, whatever?
I'm just going to do a strengths check.
You do a strengths check with advantage.
Okay.
Not 20.
19, 19, I'm going to give it to you because that's a not 20.
Uh, you grab him and you just take him with you in the ocean.
Yep.
And, uh, that's going to be the end of both you.
I don't say anything.
Okay.
I all this fight.
I did not say anything.
My mind is fully blank.
Yes.
I grab him.
I look in the eye.
My my my face is blank and we just go down together.
Yes.
And also another.
Yeah.
By the way, I am, I am not a devil producer.
Do I do I die when I fall?
No, no, no.
I'm going to ask you this.
Are you going to let him go if you dive in with him?
Or are you going to still hold on and just dive with him?
Uh, okay.
So if I like fall with him, uh, yeah.
How much do I, I don't know what's going on like.
Okay.
If you grab him with your weight, with your metal body,
you would just sink unless you leave him.
And then you try to swim back up.
You are able to do that.
But then was will do the same.
So you see that you go down with him.
We both come back.
So this is, this is a good question.
Mm hmm.
I, I don't want, I don't want Bob to die.
But I, I'm thinking what Bob would do.
Yeah.
Would Bob like think for a little bit and then use
MISTI steps to get up?
I mean, that's what that's what that's my, that was my plan initially.
But uh, now, why don't you have to do contested
constitution savings to see who lasts longer on the water?
Uh, can we do that?
Yeah, can we know that saves but contested?
Nope.
That's my call.
You either choose to dive with him or you leave him and
nothing changes essentially.
You're in the same position.
Okay.
Do I, can I, can I do any kind of a role?
Because I don't, I don't, I don't want the character to die.
But I don't want the character to die.
Okay.
I'm going to give you this.
Do another insight.
Can I do a weather manage?
Do you want Bob with this?
Uh, okay.
Another insight.
Another insight has to look at your, look at your mother again
while you're jumping off.
That's your insight.
Okay.
Since this is our, and since this is like my last time
I'll ever see her.
I want to use my portant.
That is a 17.
Mm-hmm.
And with the minus one it will be 16.
You see your mother and there
something strikes with you.
When was hit you?
In your stomach.
You felt the pain.
You looked at your mother.
You were thinking about doing what you're doing right now.
You were prepared to die.
You were prepared to kill yourself.
But you looked at the face of your mother.
And then you were like,
there are no wrinkles.
She looks exactly the same
as I left her to be.
This is strange.
Holy.
She is human.
So she has to age.
It's not the same.
Something's wrong.
This is where the last thoughts
as you leap off and die with was.
Because you realize something.
I'm going to let you know what happens.
After this turn, you're going to realize what happens.
Okay.
So can I use my bonus action now?
No, no, no.
Again, you will understand what happened next turn.
You're not dead.
That's what I'm telling you.
All right.
Thank you.
I'm just taking both of you out of the combat.
Yeah.
Sometimes you just commit to the bits.
I mean, if I
if I did not succeed this,
I would definitely have that Bob die.
Because that's what you do.
Just give me one second.
I'll reconnect my headphones.
They're fucking bugging up.
All right.
I'm back.
Hello.
I can't hear what God did.
God, fucking.
Just give me one second.
Follow me.
Okay.
Now I can hear you guys.
Bad beast, you have seen whatever's happening there.
You see Bob is just leaping off of the ship.
And he hasn't come up in the last five to 10 seconds.
Well, first I gotta get through this dude in front of me.
So let's
he's playing.
Remember, he's playing.
Yeah.
That adds.
Okay.
That's too much damage.
So that's that's the other one.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
You know what I
it's moments like these.
You want to pop your
blurry?
I feel like in this moment that I have to.
If he can I tell the people over not.
He is very low.
How low.
Madison.
He seems to have taken a hit, but he's still sad.
That's all I'm going to say.
Bring him down.
All right.
Bring him.
Go ahead 21 that's still somehow not.
Fire damage.
I don't think I don't think it does.
It just additional you know sparks of fire.
I don't think it has anything to do with the damage itself.
Well, pretty critical to all damage.
All the ice because it's same as sneak attack, right?
You don't just roll.
Oh yeah, true, true, true.
One knee, two, four roll to do.
Just remember this ruling.
So I don't forget next time.
Six that's 27.
Yeah, that's going to kill him.
Well, you want to kill him.
Okay.
So basically you just slam both your fists right into him again.
This time just tearing him off from like waste up.
And the body just falls down.
You see what happened to Bob and you just rushed to him, I guess.
Yeah, it starts lying over.
So I'll move here instead of putting my character right on that other side.
All right.
Malphith's here, turn.
Yep.
I can breath with his soul.
I somehow stayed up.
Just interruptions all the time.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Doesn't it?
That does it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let me know if you want to pop your flurry of blows or not.
No, no.
I got it.
It's four.
Four normal damage, which is going to be two.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, next is this Marine who is dead.
Dead.
And next is the lady in front of you who at this point is looking down and
trying to decide what is it worth saving boss or not.
So I'm just going to make a wisdom save.
Actually, it doesn't really have any intelligence, so it would not listen or move without
a directive.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's going to just stay there.
Is just going to stay there?
That's his turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Roma.
>> If you're telling me if we just violence or all this guy not going to do anything.
>> Yeah, I mean, that was the commands.
[LAUGH] The one who was giving commands to him was the world.
Roma.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
15.
What's your strength in your hybrid?
Is it changed?
No, it's not changed, so it's going to be same.
15.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> 15, I can't even make it across the other ship.
>> Actually, 20, because 15 is like jumping up and not like long way.
So you can jump off across here, 25, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So I can make it from there?
>> Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, so I'm a, where are we, where are we marked the 25?
I don't know where that was.
Basically, at the edge of it, you should be able to just leap off like a running leap,
and you should be able to grab the edge and pull yourself up.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Is it because of, I don't know, okay, there you go.
This marine is right here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So I pull myself up, would that be my entire turn or would I?
>> No, that's bonus.
Jump is bonus.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Whatever you want to do, that's your action.
>> Well, that shit, I'm gonna like always, I'm gonna throw this motherfucker off the edge.
[LAUGH]
>> All right, do a shred check.
That fails probably.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Get the rose.
>> 11, I'm gonna give it to you, you could throw him off.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> There you go.
Baptiste, it's your turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Before that, before that, a voice comes over the, the,
then in Mushi again, on here, on here, you, Roma, it goes.
That's a match.
Wonderland.
Get the rest, make sure the Baptiste, or whatever the other Lone Arigin's name is,
survive, take them, capture them, and report back.
Voss is second priority.
He is not important.
Do you understand?
The thing in front just nods as it starts to take like a posture of fighting in front of
you, Malfus.
>> You said Roma's next to the Dindan mushroom, right?
>> Yes.
>> I don't think Roma will let it finish in Dindan.
>> Oh, 100%.
>> But Roma doesn't have a, Roma doesn't have a reaction for that.
You could do that next time or something maybe, if you held an action to do
something, I would have let it go. But yeah, I don't think.
Because he's done a lot. He's jumped.
He has climbed up. He has thrown this guy off.
Yeah. All right. Baptiste.
>> They are.
>> Malfus and.
>> Yes. Sorry.
Bob, can you make an attack role?
Do you have anything to make an attack role from?
>> I have a few spills, yes.
>> Just click on the dagger actually.
Just make an attack role.
>> All right.
>> Am I underwater?
>> You just make an attack role.
>> All right.
>> Actually, I'm just going to let you know because it's going to be a bit confusing for
you as to what you're doing.
Yeah.
Because if I do fireballs, then I am underwater, so I don't know what this is for.
That's right.
>> Everybody from the 313, put your hand up and put your foot down.
Okay. Let me know who and then we'll see.
Okay. It's a 16.
>> Who? Who? Who? Check your DMs.
He's lighting in the DMs.
If you want to ask any clarifying questions, you can ask in the DMs.
But just let me know who first.
>> Okay. I'm just going to start.
>> Yeah.
>> Who?
>> So I'm just possessed by you now.
>> Who are you?
Okay.
Okay. Back to the East.
You.
Feel like a tug.
Like someone's pulling you out.
Like from your back, someone's like stretching you out.
Can you make an intelligence?
Actually make a wisdom.
Wisdom check.
Not stretching. It's like a tug. Essentially from behind.
>> Wisdom save.
>> But just someone is touching you.
>> All right. Wisdom check.
Not safe.
Okay. That is I'm going to DM you something.
>> Okay.
>> Here's a problem.
Bob and at least feel free to talk in the DMs.
>> Slide in the DMs.
>> And let me know what your reaction is.
At this point, mouth is and Roma, you see Baptiste fly
up behind and he's going to
Flurry of blows.
Knock out.
>> They're all at V&H.
>> Yeah, sorry.
If I were God.
Did you do?
Sorry. What was it?
One, two, three.
Oh my God.
Two grids.
And one hit.
I think. Okay.
Two grids and one hit.
Let me do the damage.
Crit.
I don't know.
I have I have matching fingers, I guess.
That's that's fours, right?
Is it what was it?
74.
I'm in the 4.
2d4, 2d4, then 54, right?
Yeah, I was like, well, 5.
Okay, 13.
18, that's fours damage, right?
All of these are fours damage.
Okay, let me check this.
>> No, forget the higher damage too.
Yeah, yeah.
Smash roll.
13 plus 18 plus.
17 plus.
21.
69.
Yeah, that's a magic number.
Also Bob, let me know what.
Okay, Bob, I'm going to send you something.
Bob, can you make an attack roll?
>> Thor.
>> And again, who?
>> God damn.
>> Okay, who?
Just choose who?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I'll do.
>> Okay.
Malfus, I'm going to DM you something.
>> Call.
>> Malfus, Baptiste, kill few.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's one more dude still on the ship.
>> And this is like he's the one driving the boat.
>> I thought he was dead.
Like I was zoomed in.
Like,
wrong with just about to jump up in the air to try to catch it.
>> No, I was thinking about like, so like,
there has to be an anchor someplace around here.
So I was thinking like, you know,
all right, that's going to be a history.
Malfus is going to make his unarmed strike
with Flurry of Blows.
Yeah, with advantage, I keep forgetting.
One, two, three.
14, 14 doesn't hit 21 hits, 21 hits, 18 does not hit, 21, 21.
I'm going to do normal.
And he's going to use flame biology
at the same time.
Can he?
No, it's like bonus action so he can't.
Plus,
two, it's going to be
six divided by two, three and three again.
That's going to be six damage.
69, I didn't do 69.
14, 21 minus, 29.
Malfus make an attack roll and tell me who.
Because I'm obsessed with why they all.
Six more.
I mean, there's no who option.
There's only one option.
So just making an attack roll.
Yeah.
I'm reading.
Yeah, what do you want to do?
Because this is technically still like kind of like time warp stuff
going on.
So the thing that is going on here is not the same time there.
So I don't think you will have enough time to do anything.
What do you want to do?
But just let me know.
All right.
Because I just want to, I think if Malfus does that,
then everyone will be done.
So I want to just check what is actually happening.
So before he does that, I want to use the magic.
Yeah, you can do that.
With my second level sales solved.
Yeah.
As soon as Roma snaps out of it,
you will be able to cast it.
Okay.
Roma, you feel the same thing,
like sort of like a tug.
And you're so sort of.
And what you now see is just Malfus,
Baptiste, and Bob, above you,
as your eyes are wide open.
And you just snap out of the dream
that you were having all having.
This was a fucking dream.
Still one.
Almost.
I was going to hit a wall.
I'm going to tell you right now.
I was just about to like cut the chain
to the fucking anchor and jump over board
to go after Bob.
You're dumb for you.
You're going to die immediately.
The person in the whole area
that can survive underwater is me.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And why I was going to wrap the anchor chain around.
The right Daniel would not survive.
We'll and say I covered not survive.
Fucking Bob.
We need to read Bob a down for it.
That was a fucking dream.
Yeah.
I mean,
I was putting sort of kind of like hints
as to like something off about everything going on.
Yeah.
No one realized though, which is, you know, that's funny.
I learned it like seven people.
Yeah, just throwing them off the ship.
All right.
You wake up.
You hear?
By the way, do you?
Did this happen in the dream?
Can we still get the XP for it?
See, this is why I said, no, no, okay.
So this is this is why I wanted to do this
because I wanted to see how your characters will react.
If Bob, you strayed away from what you as your character would do,
I would have I would have not granted you personally XP for that.
But I think everyone like did probably
the same thing they would do like if they were actually encountered with the same problem.
So after this, you get one level of inspiration, everyone.
I'll let you know how to use inspiration or how it works.
It's basically going to be one of three things.
You can use inspiration to activate one hockey, one type of hockey.
You roll a 1D20 and based on that,
you will just trigger hockey at any moment that you want to.
So if you want to trigger armament hockey,
that will add 3 AC to your current AC.
So that's a reaction essentially.
As a reaction, you can cast it anytime.
That's how inspiration is going to work.
You understand?
Yes, inspiration is just khaki unless you've mastered it.
After you master it, then you have three points allocated to your hockey.
Once you understand hockey,
you can use those three points at any point in attack, in defense,
or as a reaction, right?
Or you can use the inspiration point instead of hockey to do the same thing.
But for now, it's going to be a reaction only.
Like Luffy using his conquerors to knock people out, something like that.
Because you have no control of it as of now.
It's just going to happen spontaneously.
But above the board, you can decide when you want to use it.
Understand?
Okay.
Bob, do you understand?
Yes, sir.
Okay, there's no confusion with hockey, right?
Okay.
So I want to make sure.
Going back into the game now,
you are wake up exhausted.
So do a long rest, mark a level of exhaustion.
On your character sheet,
like around your AC, you should see like a bunch of dots.
It should say exhaustion level one,
exhaustion level three.
So just exhaustion level one, do that.
Now, Bob, can you do exhaustion level two, please?
Bob gets exhaustion level two.
Because he died.
But today you had to,
you get a level of inspiration.
I thought you were saying level.
Is there a not level?
I was like one point of inspiration, essentially.
I'm going to add like an item for inspiration,
so you can just check that off every time you get it.
But for now, just remember.
Right next to your level, there's that little button
that says inspiration, you just click it.
There's like a little...
Yeah, but that's, I mean, I guess you can remember
if you have inspiration or not, if you have that on.
But you will accumulate inspiration like in Bondersgate.
So I like that thing too.
So it's not going to reset after long or anything.
It's just going to accumulate.
So I'm just going to add an item at some point.
In your character sheet,
now there is like in your character sheet,
after your AC, in front of your AC,
there's like one, two, three, four, five, six dots, right?
Just click on the one dot, sorry, two dots.
Okay, do you know what happens on Exhaustion, Bob?
The first one is probably skill checks,
and the second one is attack and saving throw.
Yes, yes. Okay, so now long rest, everyone.
Oh, we got rid of one level, right?
Yeah, nice.
By the way, DM, before we long rest,
I mean, immediately after we wake up,
can I do because...
Yeah, cast...
Casted attack magic.
Detect magic. Do you want to cast it?
Can you cast it?
It's just the first level. I can't outcast it.
No, no, no. Can you cast it like...
What do you call it?
Ritual, yeah. Can you ritual casted?
Detect magic or not?
Yes, I can ritual.
Okay, you can ritual cast it while you're trying to sense
as to what possessed you to be pulled into this collective nightmare.
That's gonna happen while I'm gonna go to everyone,
and then I'll tell you what you detect, okay?
All right.
All right, Roma, you wake up gasping for air.
As you see, all three of you,
all three of the rest of the people around you,
and you remember what happened in your dream very clearly.
More than at any point you remember the dream very vividly.
And yeah, you can go off.
I'm gonna fucking wake up.
Fuck it.
And I'm running.
Bob's right in front of you.
And I'm gonna be like, what the fuck was that?
Bob, you were dead.
You see Bob concentrating on doing something technical
or on the place around you.
Yeah, at this point,
it fully engulfed him.
The thing is doing.
Yeah, Bob is fully focused, because not because just
of what he wants to figure this out,
also because this is the first time he felt like
his actions would probably cause harm to his parents.
So he's really focused into looking at.
I'm gonna add aroma to the chat too,
just because it doesn't matter because at this point, it doesn't matter.
Let me add or I'll go.
There you go.
Add.
Can you see it?
But I'm gonna grab Bob and I'm literally both arms wrapped around like.
Yeah.
I'm gonna grab your hair hug like.
I'm gonna hug this.
Shit out of him.
It does not really respond, but he does feel
your warmth surround him.
I take 10 damage from the hug.
I'm gonna grab one.
Okay.
Uh, that's all that's right.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's throw him anyone want to do anything?
And then I'm yelling.
Well, I'm also gonna yell for a circle in the whale.
Like.
Wow.
They've been missing for a minute.
Okay.
As you get out of like the small cabin,
you see you're here.
Also, you see through like the like doors,
which are which have like small windows on it that separates your section
from the section of the, um, what do you call it?
For the spiders?
Yeah.
The spiders grew,
sleeping another section of the ship.
As you see, they're also like kind of crawling at their
necks and struggling like sweating profusely.
Um, so what are you gonna do?
Do you want to go that way?
Or do you just want to go to see whale and cerca?
Well, it's here.
Okay.
Um, T-Ce, you just boost off up onto the deck.
Again, it's the, it's pure blackness outside.
Midnight.
All you see is just the moon shining.
And on top of the, on top of the mast,
you see whale and cerca.
Essentially in the same situation as you guys were.
Like just sweating profusely and just struggling in their sleep.
I'll go with the mom.
Hi, baby.
Daddy's on the sun.
Ha, I don't know if you have to leave.
We can stop it for now.
No, no, he, no, my son was just, he just came downstairs.
I said, uh, just let me know.
Bob, if you have to leave because I know you said,
let me know you can only go for, I think three hours or something.
I mean, yeah, I could go for a bit more.
All right.
Just tomorrow is the day after tomorrow.
That's gonna be fine.
Yes, this is fine.
I have to lock in tomorrow.
Otherwise, I'll go day.
Yeah, you're gonna be fine.
Okay, but seriously, if you have to leave, just let me know.
Um, okay.
Uh, Baptiste, you run up.
Okay.
Uh, uh, you try to wake them up.
You try to hit them as hard as you can, but it's just not working.
Uh, I'm gonna move you, uh, move from you to Malfa.
Smelfas, what are you doing?
You see the same thing as Baptiste saw, uh, as you ran up, uh, at the spiders.
Crew.
Probably hit a wall for a bit.
Okay.
You just like some anger frustrations out.
You just start to punch like a pillar, uh, in between of the lower deck,
you just punch it out as the one of your punches just goes through right through that pillar.
As that comes you down a bit.
Yeah.
Oh, sad.
One more thing for Bob to fix.
Thank you.
So what, what are you doing, Malfa?
So just doing that and that's it.
Uh, like, uh, basically, like shouting to himself, like,
"Oh, that could be real."
Okay, a rumble.
Hmm.
Coming down and just like standing there next to the broken pillar.
Mm-hmm. As you watch Bob trying to figure something out, he has like all his goggles and like
weird parts sticking out of his face, trying to look and detect something.
Roma, what are you doing?
You see Malfa's just bolted, sorry, not, uh, he's just bolted off up on the, um, mast.
Well, I'm a figure like this whole shit was real.
Like, I'm running upstairs like I'm looking for Daniel.
Mm-hmm.
I'm looking at the, again, you as soon as you like, leave the room, you see Daniel and the rest of the
crew again in the same kind of situation. See you guys were just struggling in their sleep.
So they're, they're all still asleep, right?
Yes.
They're struggling.
Hey, it's gotta be funny.
I wouldn't force best in.
Yeah.
All right.
What are you doing?
I really want to kill them.
I'm looking to try it.
Like you can try to roll.
Now, when you say it's night outside, is it a balloon?
It is a balloon.
So then wouldn't I be transforming?
Again, you don't have like full control on the so long yet.
There's a point in Ming's life that they're transforming to so long.
It's not like inherent.
He's saying he wants to kill them and have them used for a while.
Yo, that was a crazy read, bro.
I didn't get that.
No, you are not, you're not able to go so long as of yet.
So if I turn him too long, without him, will he be doing it?
Yeah, it's gonna trigger.
It's gonna trigger at some point.
But not now.
God dang it.
They're all they're all still asleep.
So then I'd be like, what the fuck just happened?
And I'm gonna be looking around.
Like I'm gonna be looking for Pipsqueak.
I'm gonna be looking for Whale.
Like where the fuck they at?
Like so you're gonna leave the lower deck and the spiders and just run up to
circle and whale.
Yeah.
Oh, you bolt up again.
Go on top.
You see Baptiste trying to like shake Whale up.
It's just not working.
He just screaming in his sleep.
On the mast.
I'm gonna grab some water and tell it on his face.
Okay, you go through the kitchen and try to get some water.
All right, Malthus, what are you doing at this point?
Um, probably go up again as well.
But we'll go upstairs as well.
Okay, you ignore the spiders again and you just go up.
Yeah.
I mean, um, just golf at the side.
Like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is happening?
All right, while you guys are scrounging around, try to, uh,
trying to wake up Whale and Cerca.
Bob, you pick up on something.
You pick up on a strange energy
radiating in right in front of you.
It's connecting to your chest and it's leading out, uh, in the hallway.
I followed.
You follow the strange energy, like a purple glowing energy.
This is like your, uh,
tech is essentially like able to like grab the energy signatures and you follow that.
You know, like in Batman, you have like fucking footstep detection, stuff like that.
Um, so, uh, you follow that.
There's strands of that energy going through your chest and toward the six folds.
Uh, sorry, not the sixfold, the spiders.
And then there's strands of that energy going upwards.
I can't hear you guys.
I think, uh, just give me one second.
Give me one second.
I'll be back.
Hello?
Uh, all right.
I'm going to move to Bob and then we'll go to you guys.
Um, so Bob, um, you follow the strands of energy and that energy again leads you up towards, uh,
either the spiders.
You can go check on the spiders or you can go up and check where the energy is leading you.
You, you can't tell where the source.
Okay, you want to find the source of it.
Let me see if you can do identify.
I should do identify.
Oh god.
Um, okay, it's up to you.
Which way you want to go at this point then?
You can go up or you can go to the spiders.
Yeah, okay.
So you go towards the spiders, uh, the glow that's glowing out of your chest and towards that
is the same amount of glow at these spiders.
Like all their chests are again connected to each other.
Like, like, like, an internet connected webway.
It's just one glow is directly leading to them, but they're not connected to you.
You understand?
Like, there's two strands coming out from top.
One is leading to you.
One is leading out to the spiders.
Okay, let me see.
Let me, let me, let me do that for you here.
Okay, let's say this is the top one, right?
This, the top one is leading somewhere here.
Uh, let me see if I can draw.
Okay, this one is leading towards you.
Like this, right?
And this is coming from the top again.
And this one is leading towards the spiders and it's going like this.
Okay, you move up and the glow is going up and up and up and connecting to whale and
cerica like this.
But the energy from the glow is very strong on whale.
Okay.
That is you get to the pocket where the rings are.
And at this point, you see the ring is glowing.
Purple.
Yes.
In the blue box that whale had the ring in, both of the rings are again connected like a
infinity symbol and to end to each other.
And this time, they're not completely black.
They're glowing purple.
Yeah, you see the energy, yeah, you see the energies are this very strong
emanating from the ring.
Okay.
Okay, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Uh, okay.
Uh, uh, I want to make sure that that is what you want to do.
Uh, okay, let me check what happens when you do that.
Because I don't think it was very good.
Uh, I'm leaning.
That damn it.
That's the, that damn it.
Uh,
Okay.
Um, I want to know where everyone is.
Where's everyone?
Right, where, where, where are you going to stand to let's say whale and cerca are here on the
mast.
Where are you guys in respect to that?
Let me move everyone close.
Everyone can, can everyone move to the ship at the mast.
And then let me know where your location is.
I'm sorry, Bob, I deleted you.
I deleted you sorry.
I'm going to move.
Uh, I'm going to put their tokens in just so you know where these guys are.
They're here, okay?
On the mast itself.
They're here.
I'm going to remove this, this, this.
I'm going to remove this fucking marine.
Well, I'm going to fucking remove the ship.
No, the, the other ship, the other ship.
That's not supposed to be there.
I should have prepared like another map of the same thing, but, you know,
I just edited the, no, I just edited the same one.
Yeah, I was lazy.
Sorry.
I know, disappointment.
All right.
So these guys are here.
Where are you guys now and tell me where you are exactly?
Okay, you're in the kitchen.
Malphus.
Okay.
Fuck did I.
Bro, I just did not expect that he went to put on the ring, but I remember writing something.
I should.
Yeah, I mean, you.
No, you didn't.
Eat it.
Baptiste did, but that didn't affect anything because the rings were not ready.
They were merging.
While worn.
Okay, fine.
Uh-huh.
You didn't send anything for last time.
I don't think.
Yeah, it was just trapped just circling around in the ring, but that's about it.
You didn't really sense anything much, but I can tell you like this time,
the difference is for sure, like the ring is pulsating with energy and it's leaking outside of it.
That's what you can tell.
Uh, okay.
All right.
Can you make an arcana check?
His end is very high.
Arcana, I don't think Bob's arcana is very high.
Okay, can you make a religion check?
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Can you make an investigation, please?
Okay, can you make a do you have a smithing tools now?
Can you make a do you just make the smithing tools roll?
I think from sapling you might have had those.
Oh, you might have gotten from the boxer thing.
Uh, okay.
Can you make a persuasion check?
Okay.
So, you failed three times.
Can all of you make a wisdom check?
Just wisdom, sorry, not safe, safe, safe, sorry, sorry.
I heard it incorrectly.
Uh, wisdom save everyone including you.
Uh, not including you.
You're fucking done.
You don't have to.
Uh, 16 to 21.
Uh, Bob.
I'm sorry, you know, Roma.
Not 20.
Okay.
What?
Yes, you failed 10, 3, 12.
Yeah.
Why?
Would you do have the bell fragment?
Will you worry?
Who?
MapTest?
Oh, yeah.
Also you guys.
Uh, okay.
Bell fragment.
I'll give you you want you succeed one.
No, actually, Rero, Rero, all of them again.
Do an arcana.
I'll take the lowest.
And then you can use the bell fragment.
I forgot like my own mechanics.
Okay.
Uh, it's the exact same.
That's crazy.
Uh, uh, uh, religion, please.
You failed this again.
Uh, the same, the one you succeeded you failed.
Uh, can you make intelligence?
Investigation yes, sir.
Investigation that's mid tools and persuasion.
Uh, investigation.
Yeah.
You failed these smits, right?
Yeah, yeah, you failed.
You failed it.
Can you make the persuasion again?
Okay, not 20.
That's going to give you two successes.
And, uh, did you get any other success?
No, we didn't.
Um, where did you actually make a check?
Religion you got success.
So that's three successes actually.
Okay.
Uh, you can put on the rank.
That's great.
[laughs]
Uh, and I know if you guys have to make the wisdom safe.
But, uh, I'm just going to let you know right now.
You have to do this daily.
[laughs]
As long as you have the rings on.
As soon as you put the rings on, they latch onto you.
And if you try to pull them off, they just don't go.
They just don't go away.
They just latch onto you.
The energy of the ring now splits.
And the rings are not joined anymore.
They're like placed separately on both of your fingers.
Which fingers do you have the rings on?
Your ring and middle.
Okay.
Cool.
Mm-hmm.
You want it on pinky and ring.
Okay.
I'm just going to tell you, none of this matters.
[laughs]
I just asked.
Just to know.
[laughs]
That makes you--
Uh, all right.
Now, you can see what, uh,
Bob is seeing the energy flowing out of your chest
from the ring, flowing into your chest.
Then that energy spreading out from the ring
to veil and surrecha, then that energy going to the others.
And then that energy going down.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
This is what I was getting to.
Let me see if I know what you check it was.
Oh, what's your base stat?
I'm sorry.
Just make a Christmas check.
Sorry.
I forgot.
Charisma.
Yes.
Okay.
You try to control the energy flowing out of the ring,
but it does not work.
It just spreads.
You can't contain it.
But you do have a sense of what is happening.
Uh, you feel the energy pulsating from--
What, sorry.
[inaudible]
Mm-hmm.
Okay. You fly 40 feet.
You fly 80 feet up in the air.
The energy from your angle seems to be
going through the cloud still inside.
Your angle, the energy is still connecting.
As you go even further, the energy splits,
but from your angle, I'll say you move another 40 feet.
But from your angle, the energy is still going.
The energy is not flowing out of the ring anymore
down in that direction is just flowing out to you.
Uh, from Bob's angle, you see the energy split,
but the lines that were connecting you are gone.
The lines connecting, these two are still there.
The lines is broken that's connecting this to the spiders,
but you don't know what the spider's condition is because you're not there.
But for whale and cerica, you still see that the both line
connecting to each other.
Tell like how much, how far the distance was.
Baptists, if you go down again, the energy will start to flow again,
downstairs, down in the air, I don't know downstairs.
Can you do another charisma with this advantage?
Because I forgot this advantage again.
For, all right, at this point, as soon as you try to control it even further,
you will kind of understand like as to what is happening,
which you see flashes of what whale and cerica and the rest of the spiders
are seeing from their perspective in their nightmares.
For whales?
Yeah, actually I should probably just see any of this.
Thank you, Bob.
[silence]
Yeah, that's what you see.
This flashes like images fed into your brain.
[silence]
That's not going to do anything.
But as soon as you go closer to whale,
the vision becomes stronger, almost as if it's trying to pull you in into the nightmare.
The thread is going to you and the thread from you is now starting to spread to whale and cerica.
You can try to restrain it or you can try to let it go.
Okay, I'm just going to make sure.
Let's say you are here, right?
So what's happening is that the energy is like this for you.
And then the energy is going to whale and then it's splitting into this.
And now the energy is starting to float through you,
but it's not connected completely to him.
You can restrain it or you can let it go and connect to whale.
You can also direct the energy to split to connect to other people or to connect to any other people.
You want to connect your flow to whale.
Sure about that.
Okay.
Yeah.
The energy is starting to flow from you into whale.
Are you flying or no?
As soon as the energy connects,
Baptiste is going to fall down.
Yeah.
Malfus, you leap in as Baptiste just closes his eyes as he falls down.
Can you make a dex check?
Yeah, you should be able to grab him and just lay him down.
Bob, you see the energy flowing and you see as soon as it got connected to whale,
it's gone.
Malfus just, sorry, Baptiste just falls down.
I got to figure this shit out, guys.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
That's only for you.
It's not only for me.
What do I have?
What excuse do I have?
Yeah.
No, as soon as Baptiste came down to this level,
the string started flowing again.
That's not the issue.
The thing is now the strings are connecting these three together
other than you four.
You understand?
Bob left.
Bob.
E-bubby-wee.
Yeah.
Actually, I'm just going to draw this shit again
so everyone understands what's happening.
The thread is leading here, here, and then here between these two.
And then the thread is leading to here, here, here, and two Malfus.
But these three are connected.
You all are connected through the common source,
let's say I'll do something like this.
None of this makes sense now.
This was useless.
What I'm trying to say is now Baptiste,
we are in Serica, are grouped up instead of all four of you.
Bob, Bob, you're the only one who can do anything about this.
The box was just a normal, like, glass box.
You don't know what the box has made of as of yet.
You haven't researched anything about the box yet.
No, no, they're still conscious.
[inaudible]
Okay, you have one, right?
Okay, you put on the sea prism, coughs on Baptiste.
The energy flowing out has not been affected.
It's the same.
He can't, he's unconscious.
[inaudible]
You can try, but it's not going to work.
He's unconscious, just like, just like,
Serica, well, he's just out of it.
You can try to knock him as much as you want, but it's just the same thing.
And soon after, Malfys, yeah, you start to see Baptiste struggling again,
like everyone else was in the dream.
Baptiste is unconscious.
Malfys is okay.
Again, you three are okay.
Only Baptiste, well, in Serica.
Yeah.
On the spiders?
Okay.
Again, yeah, but as soon as he came down, the energy connected again.
[inaudible]
No, no, they're still in the same position.
You go down, you check.
It's the same thing.
You have spells, Bob, you're the only one who can figure the shit out.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Okay.
For identify, how much money you all have together?
You need 100,000 bellies.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, you should be able to find the 200,000 bellies on him.
I'm going to say, instead of the bellies, it's basically items that you store.
And you can use these precious items to construct whatever you want to construct to a
Casor identify.
Okay.
You Casor identify on the rings and you remember this feeling.
You remember this feeling for the first time when you started to fuck with the rings.
The same empty darkness, gushes towards you, envelops you, and you hear the same voices.
Again, it's asking the same thing.
And as it says, and whispers to you, a voice whispers to you, a familiar voice.
It just whispers to you.
Come and get me free your friends.
And or let me enslaved by my boy.
That's what you hear.
New zoom out.
Yeah.
That's it.
Go ahead.
As you zoom out and just the darkness has gone, you the voice is flooded and you're back out.
He said, connect the strings.
Uh, I don't think you can carry them.
Wow, Ben is huge.
Well, I was allowed to share.
All right.
Can you roll for either investigation as or not intelligence, just straight intelligence or
or con.
Well, you know, things happen and with this advantage, please.
Come on, come on.
Hell yeah, Bob.
Clowing in into as to what you think is happening.
This is what you feel is happening.
The rings, as far as you understand them, feed on emotions, emotions, material objects,
or memories, which is basically the same thing.
So what it's doing right now is gaining more energy by feeding nightmares to the people
around how you can harness the connect the strings thing you understand it as there's only one
way to wake the people up.
Either the people inside kill themselves willingly, not like die, like kill themselves willingly,
to snap out of it.
Or they are like one of them wakes up and breaks the cycle.
What you can do to maybe enter the psyche of these of the connected group is just touch the ring
and you should be able to connect to the psyche that the or the nightmare that you're going through.
No, this has nothing to do with the movement right now.
Oh, oh, I see, I see what you mean, I see what you mean now.
Okay, cool.
What?
Yeah, you are, but right now the time is passing very differently.
So I'm just pausing it here so to see what these guys are doing, if they do something and do
something else, then different thing happen.
Yes.
So again, again, I just want to know, no, no, no, no, I want to make sure the people who are having the
dream, the people who have this nightmare, they have to die.
Not you, not that teased.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, you're going to go in alone.
No, no one's in.
Yeah.
You just, no, you just see, you just see Bob in a corner just talking to himself.
Okay, that's my sense.
Okay, that's that's that's okay.
, yeah.
Yes.
As you,
you
all right, you relay all this information that is your theory.
You don't know if it's concrete.
This is your theory.
So how do you want to act on it?
Do you want to invade these guys's dreams first?
No, no.
Hmm.
Because yeah, I think that was the rules, because he has like aid in charisma and the
rest are pretty, pretty good, pretty all around good.
Yeah, yeah, I get it.
Well, you know, all right.
Yeah.
See, again, I'm saying this.
I'm saying this is what Bob thinks.
Yeah, this is not certain.
This is just theory.
Yeah.
But the, no, again, the nightmares are shared among the people who are sharing the
nightmare.
So their nightmares are different.
Spiders, nightmares are different.
Whale and circus nightmares are different.
So these are the only two connected.
So they are having a shared nightmare.
The other three down there are having another shared nightmare.
Yeah, just test the ring.
Yeah.
No, no, down, down, everyone's down.
Uh, what are you doing, Malfus?
What are you doing, Bob?
You're saying out?
Hmm.
Just hearing.
Uh, as soon as Roma touched the ring, nothing happens.
Nothing happens.
Roma is still awake.
Yeah, he's still awake.
Nothing happens.
Yeah.
Nothing happening.
Nothing's happening.
But you do see the strands emanating from the ring to Roma.
It's just not connecting to him.
It's like two pieces of strands are like sticking out.
So it's like this.
Let me show you.
So this is, uh, let me.
Oh my god.
This is so hard to explain.
Like it not in person.
This is like, let's say this is the core.
That's a bad taste.
A strand is sticking out, but it's not connecting to Roma.
A strand, two open strands are sticking out,
but it's not connecting to anything.
They're just like weird tentacles.
It's just like flopping in the air.
Oh, it's not connecting to him.
There's two strands.
Three strands are essentially sticking out, but not connecting.
Yes.
And okay, that's, uh, yeah.
Okay, as you, okay, as Malfa's leans into knock Roma out,
you see the other tentacle kind of reacting and sticking out to Malfa's,
but it's again not connecting.
But that's one thing you.
He knocked him out.
Nothing, nothing's happening.
I'm sorry.
Yes, he is knocked out.
Again, you see the tentacles sticking out.
It's reacting as to where Malfa's is moving.
One of the tentacles, one of the tentacles reacting where Roma is moving.
But it's not connecting again.
I'm assuming you are touching the ring.
It's nothing's changing.
I'm assuming you're touching the ring.
You can dry.
You reach out to one of the strings as it attaches to you.
The other string automatically attaches to Roma,
but you are still not unconscious.
The other string is now violently like flapping towards Malfus.
Yeah.
Roma is unconscious now.
Yes.
The string is connected to you.
The string is connected to Roma.
But you are not falling unconscious.
OK.
Let me mention something.
The time is not going to pass outside.
You don't know that, but yeah.
I'm just making sure a body understands.
Bob understands that probably.
Hmm.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hi, Malfus.
Bob falls down.
No one has any idea as to what is happening,
but do we want to skip time?
How long are you going to wait, Malfus?
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
How long are you willing to wait?
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
And our pass is nothing happens.
It is still late.
You throw the bucket on Bob.
Nothing happens.
All right.
How?
You fly up.
OK.
How long?
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, oh, I see.
You try to fly Bob up.
The strand is not disconnecting.
You're flying 120.
You're still flying.
Yeah, I guess you don't see anything.
Bob's not going, like, coming back to consciousness.
[INAUDIBLE]
I mean, you never-- all of you never tried to touch the ring at the same time.
That's what I'm saying.
The strands want enough people to, like, make it work, I guess.
OK.
You wait for another hour, I guess, and you're like, nothing's happening.
Something should have happened.
They should have done something at any point.
So you just touch the ring.
Correct?
All right.
Can you-- can you guys do a long rest?
Remove all your exhaustion.
No, not remove all.
This is a dream.
This is separate from reality.
And I'm just going to be real with you.
You're going to need it because there were two ways you could have done this.
You could have first done the spiders.
And then you could have gone to the sixfold.
But you chose the other way.
So I guess we're fun.
So let's go.
Where is this sixfold, bro?
No, no, I'm completely not blaming you guys because it is a sandbox.
It is up to you guys.
And you definitely care more about the sixfolds than the spiders.
So I get it.
I mean, in your dream.
I got to make it clear.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure.
I get it.
All right.
All of you up here at the same time in this bloodied hallway.
Just swords lying around, just blood and guts spread throughout.
Just soldiers dead.
And yeah, you can see your vicinity is just blood and guts.
You hear no response.
Again, moving matters, moving, moving matters.
Okay, who's going first?
Who's going after it matters?
I'm going to just say that.
So make a formation, make a formation, and then.
Okay.
And can you sense when things are nearby aren't as they should be giving you an edge?
You can dodge away from danger.
You have advantage of the 30 saving throw.
Trap spells to gain this benefit.
You can't be blinded.
Okay.
Who's leading?
Roma.
What?
Okay.
So it's going to be Baptiste, Roma.
And then Bob.
And then Malfus.
Whenever you guys push an arrow key, just follow the first guy.
Whoever's moving.
Yeah.
As you walk toward the blood and guts come through, come through, come through.
And you start to see a stairway leading up.
Okay.
Again, on the size of you, nothing.
Just blood.
You just smell blood.
You see blood.
Got the swords lying around dead soldiers.
That's it.
No, again, you all appear at the same time.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, before you came in, there was a glimpse.
Yeah.
You do.
No, they were fighting.
Mm-hmm.
Get ready for a fight.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Can you guys hear whatever's happening?
Yeah.
Okay.
I just want to make sure.
I'm not hearing it.
What?
It probably like two, three minutes.
This is long hallway.
Okay.
You see Cerca down there, like collapsed.
One of her arms, like kind of ripped off completely.
Okay.
As you run toward, you see this being,
whatever you qualify him as,
as like purple crystals are covering its whole body,
as like golden strands are like leaking out of the back of its head.
You see, like the, you can clearly see, like the back of his head is completely hollow.
There's nothing inside.
Just the light emanating out of its body.
And it's holding whale by the neck in one arm.
[silence]
She just looks terrified.
And she uses not responding to you.
She's lying down.
Her hand is just completely torn off.
And they're all dead.
They're all dead.
Oh, oh.
Yeah.
You have one thing that you all can do.
Just let me know what.
One round before combat begins.
One action.
Because that will just immediately put you in combat, right?
[silence]
Like he moves his head, looks toward you,
ignores you as it starts to choke whale more.
[silence]
Yes, you have everything that you were, you had in real life.
So all of those resources will be replenished.
[silence]
All right.
You claim on immediately, right?
Okay.
And you're going to do knockout strike.
Do you want to move in first, Malfa?
He gets advantage.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's do that.
Well, he's grappled.
Yeah, he's grappled.
Also this guy, what you're seeing,
is also like floating in the air.
He's not touching the ground.
[laughter]
Fortunately, that's going to hit.
[silence]
Okay, let me see if I have any reactions or no.
What was it?
Okay.
You're not in your astral form, right?
Yeah, I don't know.
I think you can only do one thing.
If you want to go astral first, I'll let you do that still.
If you want to do that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that was...
[silence]
There we go.
All right.
You punch the body, you feel no resistance at all.
You just punch through him and it just feels like you're meshing with yourself.
It feels like the space warp thing that you have going on is kind of also happening.
It's absorbing the damage.
What?
You still have the rings on.
And you...
Can you make a perception actually, both of you?
[silence]
Okay, both of you on the arm that it has the sword on this arm.
You see one ring in the index finger.
An identical ring, a black ring that's glowing purple on one of its arm.
And as you punch him, Veil looks at you as he goes, "One, just one, it's not worth it.
You're going to die like the rest of them."
[silence]
16 and 4 damn.
That's going to be useful.
All right.
[silence]
Malfus, it's your turn.
What do you want to do?
All right, let me go bird.
There you go, bird.
[silence]
Oh my god, Jesus Christ, you actually hit him, okay.
Nothing.
What was it?
Four?
Four lightning, okay, let me check actually if it's...
You know what?
You do full damage.
[silence]
All right, as you hit again, the claws with the lightning touch him.
This time you actually feel the impact, but again you feel the same kind of void sucking the energy out of you.
All right, now you guys can get into combat.
I'm going to move to Roma. Roma, what are you doing?
You're shaking, Serraka.
[silence]
What's you in the point?
You're dead.
You're all dead.
Don't you see?
Oh.
The oil is going to die.
Yeah, I'm going to let me do that.
[silence]
It's going to die, so am I.
You sure not come here?
There's no way out.
[silence]
No.
There it is, is dead.
How can you fight the snake again?
Kill them.
Don't get him.
No, that's not real.
I remember.
I remember this is where we were.
This is where we were.
All right, let me.
Ecosystem saving throw.
Yeah, she's not slapping out of it.
Things, this is just reality.
[silence]
All right.
Let me get the combat.
And I'm going to put a W's.
There we go.
Why can I hear it?
What the fuck is happening?
No, I have it on.
It's just not working ever since I swished my headphones.
I'll reload.
I'll come back.
Just give me a second.
We'll look at you again.
Baptizi goes.
There's no point.
He kills Riz.
[laughter]
There's no point fighting back.
All right.
Okay.
Oh god.
I don't know what the fuck is happening.
I can't hear it.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's going to be his turn to make the wisdom save.
And if he saves, if he actually snaps out of it,
he's not going to be his turn.
Yes.
So far, he's unaffected.
Both of you have tried to punch him like as he's floating.
He has not looked at you once.
He recognized.
He acknowledged.
Bob wants, but then he just looked away.
Hmm.
All right.
Click on Handaxe and check if you can do the damage.
[silence]
Uh, 14 is not going to be enough.
Has you tried to chop off his arm or the finger?
The blade just touches it.
It just feels like a repel through the ring.
It just doesn't do anything.
It's going to be your turn unless you want to do your bonus.
Wait.
Yeah, you do get bonus because Melph is transformed.
Yeah.
So your rage would be the bonus.
Let me actually do the effect.
Let me do that.
There you go.
And, uh, yeah, that's it.
I don't know what my music is not working.
I don't want to hear this.
What?
Okay.
Oh, it's working on my other earphone.
God damn it.
Okay.
I can hear you guys.
Let's go.
Roma, that's your rage.
That's your turn, right?
And now it's going to be Serka.
I'm going to make another wisdom saving through as you charge in front of her.
She's going to fail again.
She's just not having a good time.
She's not inspired by you just running to help her.
It's the
being stern.
The thing, as you try to like knock the ring off as it looks down
and it looks at that teased and it looks at the ring.
It throws way away, like around here.
Just chucks him full force.
And he starts to calm down.
He's like about five to six feet hovering as he starts to calm down on the land.
He looks at you as he goes.
The thing I am pulled in my own nightmares.
The thing I have to face myself isn't this ironic.
What brings you here?
My dear fellows, power, strength.
Do you want the ring?
I will gladly give it to you.
Turn your nose and kill them.
And you will get what you want.
It came here for our fellows.
That is what we want.
Okay.
Let's have fun, shall we?
There's a day all the brutal and still and dull.
It's my power.
So yeah, the throw was his turn and he just drops down.
He's just facing you at this point about these.
I think that's the only way to get the ring.
Yeah.
For your turns.
The only people who are affected are enemies.
Let me check.
Each creature of your choice.
I'm going to pop the legendary resistance.
I'm flanking with the hand that has the ring on it.
That's the hand I want to punch with.
I'm hoping to make contact close to the other ring.
Look up.
The money doesn't hit first said doesn't it?
That's only because I use my bonus action for the arm stuff.
What happens at this point is as you're glying to
use the actual arms to just throw him away.
The actual arms just stop right in front of him.
You try to punch him.
But again, your fist is just blocked by his hand.
He just stops your fist with one arm.
I just discard it away.
After the end of your turn.
What?
No, the other hand.
He's going to use his legendary action at the end of your turn.
Two.
I'm looking through.
No one said it.
One is gone.
He has like 20.
He's going to use the first thing blade.
Then he's going to attack with the multi-attack.
That's an action.
The third thing blade is...
It's third thing, third thing blade.
Whenever you take the attack action on your turn,
you can attack with your active weapon twice instead of once.
Okay.
Next blade, what a lock.
So question for you.
It's similar to when I go the Yeti form.
I can use my claws twice per attack because it was a bonus action.
It was let me pop friendly to get that third attack.
This would be the same thing.
The one attack already lets you attack twice.
A multi-attack is an action that lets you attack twice.
The first one is a feat.
Where the fuck is the sword?
Where's the sword?
Command drop.
Command kill yourself.
It's on the demon.
It's going to hurt.
That's a crit.
Let me do normal.
Let me do critical.
The first one.
Yes.
Do your action.
You can do your action.
I can do that.
I don't want him creating on my guy.
That's fine.
It's a crit again.
I'm not playing this item.
This is crazy.
I love this is psychic.
You're the one who fought.
The second attack will hit for 1327.
You're knocked out.
There we go.
He lifts one of its blade.
He slices you first.
Then the second sword pierces your shoulder as it just leaves it and pushes you away.
You're not dead.
You're unconscious.
What are you doing?
You don't have to roll now.
At the end of your turn, he did a legendary action.
There needs to be advantage.
Do it with advantage.
Oh fuck off.
You try to hit the thing again.
It's just moving forward to Syracuse.
Bob.
I'm pretty sure Syracuse can do much better in combat than me.
He's going to use his legendary action to get rid of Roma.
What do you mean?
Roma is raging, right?
If it's a raise attack with the...
Yeah, I'm going to do disadvantage.
What are you doing?
How many beams are there?
He's...
15, right?
Three beams.
Another damage.
That's 5, 6 and 5.
He points his finger at Roma and three beams come out of pure energy.
Shoot out of him as chunks of your body is just gone.
What was it?
16, right?
16, 43, 16, 27.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I can't forget to take two.
Bob is certain now.
Okay, so I need to get one 30 car veil.
This is a dream wake-up or something like that.
Yeah, I'm going to make another save, but that's going to be the disadvantage.
Is that going to use my action, though?
So I'm going to do that to her and I'm going to give her my portion.
I don't know how much her is, but I got a 16, I think.
16 snaps her out of it.
She will try to rush him, but she's not going to...
What wake-up?
She can't wake up.
That's my problem.
What are you saying is not mattering at this point.
She cannot comprehend.
What do you mean proper?
I mean, she thinks that this is real, but I'm trying to convince her that this is not real.
This is a dream.
The wisdom saving throw is...
You can try saying that to her, but it's not going to change anything.
You can only try to convince her to fight back.
That's all you can do.
Right, so can I tell them that Roma is about to die?
Yeah, she's going to snap out of it.
She's going to get up.
She looks at the whale.
She looks at Roma and she goes...
Okay, she gets up.
What is she trying?
I'm pretty sure she can do a lot of damage.
Who do I do it on?
I'm going to look at Roma and say, "Hey, do you want to breed fire?
Are you good at punching?"
Am I good at punching from my whole body?
That's what I...
No, no, no, no.
No, you saw Baptiste hit him and see that stuff wasn't working.
That's what I ask you.
Do you want to breed fire?
Are you confident that you can hit him?
I'm confident in shit.
You just made just eight three blows.
I asked you if you want to breed fire or not.
Hell yeah, let's do it.
I'm going to come over here.
No, I can't turn you into a dragon, but I'm going to come over here
and look at dragons bred on Roma.
Look at that.
And since I saw lightning, like, actually do stuff,
so I'm going to give lightning bred to Roma.
No, that.
And I'm going to run the as much like I'm going to run away.
Oh, well.
As you get close to Roma, touch him,
basically implant like a small fire thrower on him
with like a small yellow capsule inside.
You run away.
At the end of your turn,
the thing is going to look at you.
And it's going to do another one of his attacks.
It's because I need my concentration up.
Is it an attack role?
Let me check.
I'm just trying to figure out what at this point would be.
Yeah, I think this is the one.
Well, there you go.
I need a constitution safe from you.
Wow, I did not want to have a constitution safe, but here it goes.
Yeah, that's not going to work.
It lifts up a finger and just an,
yeah, it just lifts up a finger and Bob,
you just immediately just explode.
Next is, so do I go do I get out of that server or something?
No, no, no, no.
It's staying there, stay here.
Next is, well,
well, it's like behind you.
Melfas, do you want to say something to him?
Yes.
Okay.
So is he still being a bitch in the corner?
He is just like down his legs.
You see one of the legs is just bleeding and yeah,
he's just out of it completely.
He wouldn't have saw a server and then like I got to go protect her.
He hasn't seen anything yet.
So I'm going to place a hand from this.
Let some lightning float through him.
I'm going to move.
I go ahead, go ahead.
If you don't want to use your own use mine, well, this one,
I don't double the wave,
a dissuers sister has man enough to fight.
It looks up and looks at Serika and he realizes,
okay, this is not right.
He has to do something about it.
He's going to make another wisdom check with advantage.
All right, that's good enough.
Okay, he gets up, goes.
Thanks.
I needed that.
Look.
Promise me something.
If you all die here, you'll take her away.
Let me do it together.
No, no, she comes first.
Take her away.
You run as far as possible, the fastest possible.
Can you promise me that?
I won't let yours be taken to save those mine.
Okay.
He is going to Ricochet Jab.
Actually, I don't think that's going to work.
I'm just going to quit blade three times.
Quit blade, quit blade, quit blade.
One fails 20, 27.
Okay.
Do something well, please.
Well, don't be me.
Do something.
It's a five, that's a four.
Okay.
That as well, you see, you see, we'll just
fucking jumping from point to point, like here, then here, then here, as he finally
lands like right behind, about east, right, right, right, beside about east, as the
being just takes like slices off of the thing.
Again, it's like just flowing matter, just reconstructs itself.
Roll with your turn.
Yep.
All right.
You know what time to.
Smacking time.
No, it's time to go fucking.
Yeti time.
Where is it?
Or is it, or is it.
There you go.
Oh, should I see anything?
Oh, let me fix that.
Just for the sake of it, I'm just going to turn it into the morning so everyone can
see.
Does it matter anymore?
Well, Bob is dead, so he got some shit.
I'll just die.
I'm sorry, Bob, but you're going to have to hold on for a second.
Yep.
And I'm literally just going to move like five feet that way.
Okay.
And then what is it, uh, fucking.
You got a DC 12 depth.
Stairady saving throw.
Fucking a critically succeeds.
I don't know what the fuck is up with my roles today, but it's crazy.
Uh, is that your turn?
No, I'm going to swipe just one time.
No, you transform, right?
That's your bonus and then this is an action.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess, yeah, I guess that's it.
At the end of your turn is going to turn towards you.
Is it goes?
One of those again.
I guess the circle of life continues.
So tiring.
What should I do with you?
Uh, he's going to cast.
[BELL RINGING]
There you go.
Stairady, please.
Is that an action?
But then I can't grab you.
I guess he can grapple.
I wouldn't be able to fit.
It's only a medium creature.
I'm under.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
It is.
I can't.
Well, I guess that's a wasted move.
Uh, but he'll try to grab well.
Let me do a contested strength.
Hold on.
Should be circus.
Oh, I guess no, no, no.
The legendary action would be just, yeah, just summoning that thing.
Okay, he's not going to make a move yet.
So circus move.
Circa is going to see whatever's happening.
And she's just going to charge.
And at this distance, she's going to transform one of our arms into rocket launchers.
Rocket launcher shoulder.
66.
I'm going to make a deck save first.
Oh, he actually critically fails.
Nice.
He's going to burn his legendary resistance.
He already did.
He has multiple.
And that's going to take 13 more damage.
Or as the impact just explodes right in front of him, you see like the, the
shrapnel hitting its body as the shrapnel then after a few seconds,
just pop out and fall to the ground.
The smoke clears the thing basically looks unharmed as it just keeps moving.
It's going to look at you, Roma.
And it goes.
You're too big to fit through that now.
He tries to grab you.
And he's going to swing his vicious sword twice.
So vicious.
Oh, my God, he actually misses both of them.
What?
Yeah.
This is rough.
I didn't want it.
I don't know if that's safe.
Oh, almost a crit.
No.
You're seeing all of your fellows being picked off one by one.
Bob is dead.
Can I grab up this?
You can.
Yes.
You're going to give a bit of a little help in moving so I'll be here.
Yeah, grab up this with me and just go through his back to the healing.
All right, let me do that.
You grab the healing kit.
You're just going to use it on him.
Okay.
Do you have the healing kit?
Can you roll for it?
I don't have.
But I can just throw 2d4.
Let me see if it's 2d4 plus 2.
It's 2d4 plus 2, yeah.
Seven.
At least you wake up with 7 hit points.
You come to consciousness as you see like the blade still kind of bleeding.
Wherever he hits you with the blade is still kind of bleeding.
It does hurt in the dream.
You do recognize it's a dream, but it still hurts.
At least be man.
You there.
Where's he at?
He's right there.
So is that grabbing taking a moment?
I'm going to say that's an action and the bonus would be injecting.
Yeah.
Not okay.
At the end of your turn, he's going to
look at you as you run away with Baptiste.
Oh, actually, can he?
Okay, let me know one thing.
In case of Warlocks, you can choose spells to be like instantaneous, right?
At Will's spells.
I don't know what they're called.
How many do you have?
Oh, you have one of one.
It's like some book of something.
I don't know.
I was looking into it.
Oh, Mystic Arcaneum.
Yeah, that one.
I think you can only use one spell one.
So finger of death, I can't use anymore.
Oh no.
Whatever shall we do?
All right.
Make a con save, everyone.
I can't just tell.
What the fuck, bro?
So Bob, the world dies now.
Bob is dead already, so he doesn't need to.
Anyone got more than 18?
Okay, use the bell fragment.
Roll again.
As soon as you reach for the bell fragment, you see the creatures had turns towards you.
Okay, now use the bell fragment.
Same check.
It's not safe.
You just have to re-roll.
Oh my god.
Essentially, what happens is just a black void unleashes off of him.
And just all you see is blackness and then it's all over.
All of you snap back to reality.
I can't, no, everyone.
Everyone is out.
Wait, did you survive?
Sure, sure.
I really are really doubted.
32.
Okay, okay.
I didn't know.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right.
Who's dead, though?
Circus dead.
Vail is dead.
Baptiste actually is now this time.
Wait, are you down or dead?
It's the Karatek.
28.
He has seven HP.
He's also done.
Okay, I assume it was high damage.
Okay, let me check.
Damn.
I wanted to make it easier for you guys, but who?
Wouldn't it hit him as well?
No, no, no.
The castor does not get damaged.
I mean, I can read Circle of Death.
I mean, if you cost fire by only yourself, you also did.
Yeah, fireball.
A sphere negative energy ripples out in 60-foot radius from the point within the range.
Each creature is in that area.
Oh, yeah, it's like fireball.
Okay.
You know what, just to save time,
I'm going to say he's going to cast it at level seven.
Damage increases by 2d6.
We would still be uproar, man.
Four.
I'm going to cast it more.
2d6.
What level spell start does he have?
Nine.
Two d6.
Six.
Is that enough?
Nine.
You know what?
I'm just going to keep it at what it was.
What was it?
32?
32.
So I don't need to write fucking keeping up casting it.
Bob is dead.
Circa is dead.
Whale is dead.
You're unconscious, right?
Yeah, you're unconscious.
You are out of bird, and you take two more damage to your normal farm.
Let me do that for you.
There you go.
Roma, you take how much was it?
32.
Not 32.
45 minus 32.
13.
Yeah.
Let me put the music back on.
I'm still fighting.
Who's turn was it?
Roma.
No, no, at the end of Memphis is turned.
He did the thing and now it's your turn.
So I'm going to be like, you killed them.
What the fuck do you want from us?
I think in front of you, kind of size.
Correct.
None of this matters.
There are dead.
So will you be.
I recognize this isn't real.
If you want to keep fighting, you can keep fighting.
There's another option we can talk.
Okay.
Fuck it.
I'm going to hear you out.
So I'm just going to behold myself.
The creature at this point crouches down.
As he looks at like the dead bodies of whale and cerica,
just throws them away.
Like here and here.
To think I didn't even recognize I was trapped in one of my own conjured nightmares.
He points at Baptiste.
As Baptiste, you just came back to life with both health.
And he just grabs like the air as Baptiste is pulled in closer to him.
As he puts you in like a hold by the neck, Baptiste, he says,
"So what are you planning with my power?"
It keeps pulls me in.
I would like to try to contest it.
It's like pull to try to pull the ring of his feet.
Okay.
Who has a bigger pool?
He succeeds.
So you try to do the pull.
He chuckles himself.
Goes, "Faiste, watch this time again."
Well, at least this time you managed to grab two of them instead of just one.
You want this to you?
Baptiste?
What is it?
He's asking you.
Oh, you're...
Okay.
It's a show that Versus to bring me back.
And you're going to help me if you want to get out of this nightmare.
Okay.
I'm your patron child.
I'll be carrying your patron as soon as you put those rings on.
Now give me a croitance.
Will you serve me and bring me back?
I'll be useful with this power like the rest of them.
How do you mean by serve you?
Bring me back to life, find my vessel, revive me.
And I can finally conquer this world much like the rest.
Why don't you?
You can imagine why.
Would you not be me away?
Do you not fear me?
No.
Okay.
I have called cap on that.
Can you do a wisdom check?
Actually, do deception.
Because you are...
No, you're not being honest.
You can't kill bro in one hit.
You're not telling me that.
You saw a Bob literally explode with one.
I'm not.
Was that intelligence?
No, I don't want to do intelligence with the fuck man.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah.
Do wisdom.
Save.
No one.
Yeah, you're shooting your pants man.
Do a deception.
I'll give you an option.
Otherwise I would have said no.
You see the right through you.
I'm not worried about that.
Command the ultimate power in this universe.
At least in yours.
What would it be?
You think you have an option?
You're ring sign.
There is no choice for you.
I'm going to want you every waking moment of your life.
Tell me you're given.
Tell me you're given to my demands.
You're fined my whistle.
You hand the ring over.
This is not the end.
You have to find the rest.
What happens if he just cuts off the ring and throws them in the ocean?
You're not going to give us something.
My go.
Well, we got lucky this time that you got to face me.
Next time it won't be me.
Do it be just some congeneration of some nightmare that you possess.
Someone else possesses near you.
You never know.
I'm through one nightmare already.
What's up you more?
Very well.
Hope we have our meeting next time.
As he says those words, all of you wake up on the ship.
This time both of the six volts are awake as well.
As they're just gasping for air as they do not know what the fuck is happening.
It is almost the same time as you left, Malfast.
You do not see any shred of sunlight or any changes in the waves of the ocean.
Around yourself, you're an navigator.
You don't see when changes or anything that would indicate that you're in a different location.
How's Bob doing?
Bob is back awake.
Bob's dead.
Last thing he saw was just a finger pointed at him and that's it.
Bob, you do not have any recollection of the talk that these guys had with the thing.
Oh man, that was scary.
Hey guys, what happened?
Why did that guy wake me up?
He didn't wake you up.
I don't know that.
I don't know about the explosion.
Oh, you see you think you pointed at you and you just woke up.
I say, okay, sorry.
You scared of me.
He didn't want me to be there so he woke me up.
Yeah, I said, I think Bob should believe that.
I'm going to check on the spiders.
Guys, what happened?
Roma, you see the spiders are still like having the same nightmare.
All right, I'm going to walk up and tell them.
Oh no, now do we have to go into their nightmares?
We got to go save them.
Do we need to?
We have a ship now.
I mean, you can wait.
You can wait a whole day and see what happens.
By the way, can you mark off one more exhaustion levels?
Everyone, please.
Bob, can you take two more?
I do wish.
I'd work on that.
Four, yeah.
You had four, Bob.
We long rough and then do the exhaustion.
Well, if you load us twice.
No, just long.
You know what?
I'm just going to do the long rest and everything for you guys.
And then I'm just going to mark the exhaustion.
There you go.
The rest two.
So the beating will make me a little bit more stressed.
Four.
Well, why do I have four now?
I have already had two.
You died twice.
It's stacking.
Yeah.
If you die on the next one, Bob, I'm sorry.
It's over.
Yeah.
Uh,
So we'll also wake up and they look at you guys.
What the hell was that?
Oh, God.
It's like my worst nightmare coming to life.
What the hell happened?
I thought I died.
Jesus Christ.
Where the fuck are those wings?
What happened?
He sees the box open again lying beside him.
That's why he asked this.
Well, you think someone's going to say anything at all?
I didn't hear anything you said.
Did anyone hear anything?
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
You say yourself your worst nightmare scheme is a joke.
I don't know what you're saying.
She looks at you.
Yes.
But we killed them.
As far as I remember, we killed them.
We took care of them.
You didn't.
We just had that ring and then he started acting differently.
Well, it wasn't the king.
It was the king's youngest son that took over.
It was complicated.
I don't know.
I'm just exhausted.
Oh my God.
My arm.
I lost my arm.
Jesus Christ.
Oh God.
Both of them jump off of the mass and go down to you.
Roman, as it goes.
So what's the plan?
Do we?
Are the three of them trapped?
Like us?
Yes.
Oh God.
So what do we do now?
Well, please.
We have to somehow get into their dreams somehow in table.
What did the guy say at the last?
I went out.
I didn't hear anything.
I think it first perfectly that you don't know.
Yeah, that's why this.
Yeah, that's up to Baptist.
You can ask Baptist.
So what the hell happened after you were gone?
Or after you woke up?
Or if you don't recognize that all of you just woke up at the same time when you woke up,
then you won't ask.
Okay, Baptist, buddy.
I need you to respect.
You're going to lose two levels in monk and you have to gain two levels in warlock.
So let me know what you want.
Yeah, well, that's unfortunate.
All right, for next time, we need to get that prepped.
And other than that, I already have the spiders thing prepped.
Oh, look at that.
Well, it should have been easier.
This one should have been easier if you went through the spiders first,
because then you would have three more allies.
That's not the issue.
If you had the spiders, the chances of one of you dying would be lower.
But that's like meta gaming, I understand.
You could have died.
You need to understand.
This is like the main fucking BBEG, Equivalent Guy.
So I have to make him strong.
I can't be just like throwing people which are moderately strong at you guys always.
Also, I'm going to be real honest with you.
I did not expect you to do as much as you did for the first combat encounter.
It was crazy.
By the way, so we finally encountered our BBEG.
You don't know.
I'm going to say this.
You already recognize that this was the BBEG for the six falls.
But it necessarily doesn't have to be the BBEG for your campaign.
It depends on how you handle it.
If you go out and find the rings, if you actually seek out this plotline,
it will go differently.
If you just mind your own business, it will go differently.
But now that the rings are on, I think there's less chance of that happening.
Yeah, he kind of stuck with that now.
Unless we cut his fingers off.
If you want to try it, feel free to.
Hey, BBEG.
How much do you enjoy your ring and pinky finger?
Well, that's a decision for you, BBEG, for the next session.
And you can be Yoda.
You can get.
Augmentation.
To have his pinky and ring here.
I mean, yeah, I don't have half of my body.
Yeah, Bob, just build up a finger.
All right.
I need to know Starsten Vicious now.
So I can leave, please.
Well, I really thought today was going to be just that initial fight, but no, here we are.
I fucking loved it.
That's all I can do.
Like this whole fucking thing, I fucking loved it.
I just like, because like no offense, like I got to kill the spiders.
Like I wanted to originally.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, it was like the way I killed Daniel.
Five four.
Like, it's all on top of it.
Just sits down.
Sit on him.
You like, you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I was sitting.
Vicious.
I still want to meet a paladin or somebody who can bless my fine hand.
I get it again.
I needed a tuned real quick.
Uh, holy, why is it on it?
I don't know what they do.
I don't know if you had a paladin with you inside, it might have been better.
Well, we haven't come across one yet.
Yeah, exactly.
Bob, what you got for me?
I'm sorry that you are for exhaustion, but I'll try my best.
Vicious.
Yeah, I mean, we saw the VVG.
We even know we need level of faster.
Let's get to an orphanage and get a little bit of peace.
Okay.
Nice.
So stars, stars of the session.
I mean, the whole campaign was pretty awesome though.
At the fact, the moment you said my mother died, I, that was like, I mean,
I don't know where.
Yeah.
That was a peak emotion at that moment.
Okay.
So did you, did you guys talk to each other when I, when I asked you guys about the nightmares?
No.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool.
Like, let's keep it that way.
Oh, I fucking hate you, bro.
Yes.
Why are you asking again?
I mean, I asked you guys your nightmares, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I said you three examples.
I know.
No, no.
I just chose to go another way, but I do need to know specifics because I didn't know who was going to like do the ring thing.
So I was preparing just in case if you, if who's going to be guts from now on.
So whoever's going to be guts, get fucking ready.
I feel like the rings was originally meant for Bob.
They're not meant for anyone.
I don't want to.
Whoever chooses, yeah, whoever chooses to have it, you have it.
They're meant to be put away.
Honestly, if this like is, is a game, it's like a littered powers, you know.
The only reason I put them on is because there seems to be no other way to stop them from being.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get it.
You had no like actual clues as to do what the fuck you have to do, but I get it.
So Bob, any any wishes?
XP.
Other than XP, please.
Not any wishes for the campaign wishes for the almighty that I don't die.
I don't.
Yeah, I just want to make sure I'm not the bad guy.
This is the dice, man.
This guy is crazy.
I don't know that more than mouth.
I don't know that more than anyone else.
I don't know if you saw the bread and clip about the dice.
It's so funny.
Where he says like, the dice is just this guy doesn't listen.
Anyway, yeah, you can head out Bob.
Thank you.
And I'm sorry.
It's to whatever the psychic damage I can do.
All right.
Yeah.
Maybe we can work on something that might let you hit more.
Maybe that he has like better chances of hitting when he's flanking with the knockout track.
At least, even if he doesn't hit, he at least does damage when he does.
So maybe we figure something like that.
Yeah.
Maybe we might need to figure something out for that.
Maybe we have an idea.
I'll have an idea.
You stuck with him now.
Yeah, you're stuck with him, man.
Unless you want to chop him off.
Should I put him on?
So Bob finally said that he wants to get something.
Yeah.
Good.
Mm-hmm.
I will talk about that.
Again, there's not a foolproof thing.
I just want to make sure everyone understands.
He said try it.
That's all he said.
Yeah, I mean, you can try it.
Oh, yeah.
I have a magical body.
Mm-hmm.
It's like fingers with.
Yeah, I mean, you.
You can try again.
Um, Memphis, any, any wishes?
We.
As long as the first part is not real.
That would be good.
All right.
The moment you said like this is a wiggit thing.
I was like, what the fuck?
Fuck you.
Yeah.
And especially like the dream part.
I know.
You were the second to last to wake up, right?
Yeah.
I was fucking, I don't know what was going on through
Rome's head when I started taking control of every character.
I don't know what was happening.
What do you mean?
I started rolling for the characters, right?
Mm-hmm.
So what were you thinking?
What was happening?
I was like, what the fuck is going on?
Because like in my head, like I'm thinking like I still got to go say Bob.
Like.
I cut the chains of the anchor, wrap it around, jump in the water, go after that.
And then all of a sudden, like the screen goes black, like, I was like, what the fuck is going on?
All right.
I get it.
I mean, it's rough.
Baptiste.
This shit, like I said, this shit dope.
Like I'm in.
Well, you know, I said, the pain's incoming.
I warned you guys.
Pain did come.
In multiple ways.
Especially to Bob.
Yeah.
Bob was like, what the fuck?
Baptiste, what you got for me?
Stars and wishes.
To not be a warlock.
That's my case.
Okay.
If you feel that's strongly about it, I have suggestions.
And the meaner what you want in that case.
So I was thinking.
If you respect your stats, it needs to be the same.
So if you have like a minus.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
That's the, that's the main issue, which I'm also thinking of.
So I'm thinking that instead of doing like a class change,
I'll just treat it as like a magic item.
You have your current things.
And on top of that, you have the magic items.
Like, you know, Haleyne get reflexively did like Eldridge Blast
and whatever, right?
Melfus.
In our initial session when he put the rings on.
So I was thinking that should be something.
Let me, let me list off the stats that you get from the ring.
Aren't the like the magic things that you get from the ring.
All right.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Got my way.
Okay.
There you go.
You have expanded spell casting as a world of pack boon source.
So I'm just going to do expanded spell casting like Melfus is doing based off his decks instead of charisma.
Okay.
Or based mine is based on wisdom.
So wisdom, sorry, same, same for you then wisdom.
You gain two Warlock spell slots and you can choose any two Warlock spells that you want.
You let me know what uses wisdom for spell casting.
Gain access to the following spells uses ring slots.
Ring slots are different from your general spell slots.
If you have two rings, it's going to be your level.
So I'm just going to say four, right?
Four into two.
It's going to be eight.
So you get eight spells of these Elded Blast, Hex, Helish, Rabuk, Darkness, Mirror Image.
Every time you use any of these, one of the slots will be cleared.
Go.
You get Eldridge boon.
You get agonizing blast effect, add your wisdom modifier to the Eldridge Blast damage.
You gain Devil's Site.
You can see through darkness essentially.
Blind site, blind site essentially.
I mean, for flavoring, I think blind site would work because there's no such thing as darkness.
I guess there is.
We'll see.
We'll rule it when it comes up.
I don't think it's going to come up honestly that much.
What?
Can you say something?
That's an echolocation.
Eash long rest, a roller DC 13 wisdom save.
On a failure, you suffer a nightmare vision.
Take one level of exhaustion and experience vivid illusions.
If this happens three nights in a row, your alignment will temporarily shift from chaotic
neutral to whatever, you know, whatever your current alignment is to evil every time.
And you will have to play that character again.
I won't hear none of this nonsense that I'm not intimidated.
Can I give all this in writing?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just going to copy paste this and send it to you so you prepare for this for the next time.
I have it written anyway.
[humming]
There you go.
So just for you, I'm not going to do it.
I mean, I do feel like it's probably not good to respect.
I think it's better to treat it as a magic item.
Also, this is because you have two rings.
If you had only one, the abilities you get from it will be lesser.
I'll try to play my part as best as possible.
Yeah.
I'll call you on your bullshit if you don't.
But I truly don't think he wants to actively help that man.
Yeah, I mean, I get it.
In character, if you don't want to help it, you can try to get rid of the rings if you want to.
Again, it's up to you what you do with the rings.
I'm just telling you what your options are.
But you know, this is how it works.
Curse items.
It's just, it's just, you know, this is what it is.
I was very clear from the where beginning, even with like, Malfus's group.
I was very good.
This thing is not good.
I never, never have just a.
Yeah.
I mean, Malfus knows because he's seen stuff happen.
I guess Baptiste in character would not know like what exactly happened.
So it makes sense.
I'm not saying like whatever you did was wrong.
And there's no wrong option.
It's based off what you're feeling at the moment.
That's fine.
Also, I got a fucking stop with this fucking praverly voices.
I think I'm going to fucking lose my larynx.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll find.
You guys next week.
And if we have some time to play BG2, you'll see.
So you guys then.
So back to my attack on Titan.
Bye bye.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What you want.